Hey everybody, so this is going to be a really, really interesting episode. A lot of folks are interested in big data. Big data is still hugely, hugely important. It's still growing at a really, really fast pace. There's so many companies that are figuring out how to manage a lot of information that is coming through and how to harness that and how to use it to make better products. And so we're here to talk with Frank McSherry, who's the co-founder of Materialize, who's going to really kind of walk us through really what is real-time data streaming, how that works under the hood, and how everyone else can kind of get their hands on
大家好，这一期节目将会非常、非常有趣。很多人都对大数据感兴趣。大数据依然非常、非常重要，而且仍在以非常、非常快的速度增长。许多公司都在摸索如何管理海量涌入的信息，如何驾驭这些信息，以及如何利用它们来打造更好的产品。因此，我们今天请到了 Materialize 的联合创始人 Frank McSherry，他将带我们深入了解什么是实时数据流，它的底层原理是什么，以及其他人如何才能上手使用这项技术。
this tech. So thanks a lot for coming on the show, Frank. Oh, it's not a problem at all. It's my pleasure. Cool. So how are you handling the COVID situation, the work from home? How has it kind of changed your day to day? Yeah, it's maybe unsurprising. It's changed everyone's day to day pretty substantially substantially we went from being a group of people who are basically all in the same room more or less you made a sort of 16 person office that everyone showed up and worked and you know a certain collaboration style and that sort of pivoted 100 180 degrees to everyone is somewhere else and you know it's in some ways good like from my point of view we need to be a lot more thoughtful
非常感谢你来到我们的节目，Frank。哦，没问题，这是我的荣幸。太棒了。那么，你是如何应对新冠疫情和居家办公的？这在多大程度上改变了你的日常生活？是的，这可能并不令人意外。它在很大程度上改变了每个人的日常生活。我们从一群基本上都在同一个房间里工作的人——大概是一个 16 人的办公室，每个人都到场工作，有一种特定的协作风格——转变成了 180 度的大转弯，每个人都在不同的地方。从某种程度上说，这也有好处，比如从我的角度来看，我们需要对沟通和流程等事情进行更多的思考。
about our communication and our processes and stuff like that. You can't just yell at someone to try to figure out how a thing works. You have to ideally write it down and everyone can see at that point. I don't know, but super disruptive, yeah. How do you handle that situation
你不能只是对着某人大喊大叫来弄清楚某件事是如何运作的。理想情况下，你必须把它写下来，这样每个人都能看到。我不知道，但这确实非常具有破坏性。你是如何处理那种需要寻求帮助的情况的？
where someone needs to ask for help? I found this is a real challenge with our team is it used to be you kind of just yell and whoever, uh, someone will just, you know, kind of jump in. But now it's like, if you posted the chat, it's kind of a little bit more disruptive and there's this kind of Mexican standoff among all the folks in the chat, like who's going to answer this. And, uh, yeah, I was wondering how, how do you deal with that? It's you're right. It's, it's definitely a little tricky. I think at the moment, at least we, how do you deal with that? You're right. It's definitely a little tricky. I think at the moment, at least, we're still, you know, things are changing, of course,
我发现这对我们的团队来说是一个真正的挑战。过去，你只需要喊一声，无论谁，呃，总会有人跳出来帮忙。但现在，如果你在聊天软件里发消息，这会显得有点突兀，而且聊天群里会出现一种“墨西哥僵局”，大家都在看谁会去回答。呃，是的，我很好奇你是怎么处理这种情况的？你是对的，这确实有点棘手。我想目前，至少我们……你是怎么处理的？你是对的，这确实有点棘手。我想目前，至少我们……事情当然在变化，
but we're small enough that there's still some sort of sense of ownership for who is in charge of a certain thing. And that person might not be looking at the moment, but there aren't a bunch of people saying, oh, not me. I didn't do it. Generally, there are enough folks who are interested in sort of the health of the good and stuff like that, that someone will pipe up and say, like, I thought it was this, or here's a PR that looks relevant. Maybe that's where the problem is. Yeah, makes sense. Makes sense. Yeah, I think I've been telling folks to try to do point to point,
但我们规模足够小，所以对于谁负责某件事，仍然有一种归属感。那个人当时可能没在看，但不会有一群人说“哦，不是我，我没做”。通常，总会有足够多关心项目健康状况的人跳出来说：“我觉得是这样”，或者“这里有个相关的 PR，也许问题出在这里”。是的，有道理。有道理。是的，我想我一直在告诉大家尝试进行点对点沟通，
like it might be easier to message one person and that person tell you go some like, it's actually this other person, then you message the group because you end up in this situation where uh potentially maybe no one answers and and everyone's kind of looking at each other but but yeah i think that all of these things and and whiteboarding is another thing i've found to be a real challenge but all these things i think will will be able to make you know that we'll be able to sort of make progress in these areas it's just going to take time yeah no it makes it very clear that this is, for me at least for sure, this was an underappreciated aspect of how do you get work done. We can certainly, we're faking it a little bit now in terms of figuring out the right ways to communicate, but clearly people who are good at
比如直接给一个人发消息可能更容易，如果那个人告诉你“其实是另一个人负责”，那你再去联系那个群组。因为如果你直接发群消息，最终可能会陷入没人回答、大家面面相觑的境地。但确实，我认为所有这些事情，包括白板协作，都是我发现的真正挑战。但我相信，随着时间推移，我们一定能在这些领域取得进展。是的，这让我非常清楚，至少对我来说，这确实是工作中一个被低估的方面。我们现在在寻找正确的沟通方式上确实有点在“假装”，但很明显，那些擅长
remote first, for example, it's impressive that, oh, wow, you must have some great processes in place, or just fundamentally different ones, but clearly more robust to someone isn't available for a little while, or someone's sick or something like that, and they're just out for a bit. Can your org resist that? It's neat stuff. And I hadn't really thought very hard about this at all beforehand. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Yeah, it's wild how it just kind of happened right away. I mean, I still actually have, you know, a bunch of little tokens and picture frames and stuff at my desk, I think. I mean, I don't even know if someone cleaned them off or not.
远程优先工作的人，令人印象深刻。哦，哇，你们一定有一套很棒的流程，或者从根本上就不同。但显然，如果有人暂时无法工作，或者有人生病了，他们只是离开一会儿，这种模式会更稳健。你的组织能抵御这种情况吗？这很有意思。我之前真的没怎么深入思考过这个问题。是的，确实。这太疯狂了，它就这样发生了。我的意思是，我的桌子上其实还有一堆小纪念品、相框之类的东西。我甚至不知道有没有人清理过它们。
But, you know, it's just one day we were told not to go into work. And so it's just kind of like, I wonder if it's just, if it's just a snapshot of March, 2020 over there. I mean, I don't, I can't even get in the building. So I don't know. We had that for a bit. We had someone go in, we were at a, we work essentially. And our, our lease was up at some time in June or so. And we had some folks go in and basically put things in boxes and put addresses on them and ship them. So you got like a, essentially a care package, which was this was the stuff that was on your desk, which is a bit like, well, it's nice to have,
但是，有一天我们被告知不要去上班了。所以这就像是……我不知道那是不是还停留在 2020 年 3 月的样子。我的意思是，我甚至进不去那栋楼。所以我不清楚。我们有一段时间是这样的。我们有人进去过，我们当时在 WeWork 办公，我们的租约在 6 月左右到期。我们让一些人进去，基本上把东西装进盒子里，贴上地址寄出去。所以你基本上收到的是一个“关怀包裹”，里面就是你桌子上的东西。这有点像……嗯，有这些东西很好，
but it's also a bit weird to think, like basically just been moved out or something. Yeah, totally. It's very emotionally jarring, a lot of the stuff. I'm sure for many people for many different reasons, but that's also been a big problem, I would say. There's the mechanical aspect of writing code and building a business,
但想到基本上就是被搬出来了，感觉也挺奇怪的。是的，完全同意。这在情感上非常令人不安，原因有很多。我相信对许多人来说也是如此，这也是一个大问题。编写代码和建立业务有机械的一面，
but there's also just big emotional attacks on a lot of folks who are trying to get their head around the world being different and stuff like that. Yeah. Yeah. Totally makes sense. So, so let's rewind from, from the materialize in the, in the, we work and let's kind of start from the beginning and kind of what's your backstory and what kind of led to you co-founding Materialize? Yeah, okay. Well, it goes back a ways.
但对于许多试图适应这个不同世界的人来说，这也是一种巨大的情感冲击。是的，完全说得通。那么，让我们从 Materialize 和 WeWork 的话题中跳出来，从头开始，聊聊你的背景，以及是什么促使你共同创立了 Materialize？好的，这要追溯到很久以前了。
Tell me if, no, that's too far. Speed it up. No, go for it. I mean, you could say, you know, first there was the womb and then- Yeah, yeah. No, I think like in terms of formative moments, you went to grad school, standard computer computer science education went to grad school which is maybe a
如果太远了就告诉我。加快进度。不，请继续。我的意思是，你可以说，首先是出生，然后……是的，是的。不，我想就形成性的时刻而言，你读了研究生，接受了标准的计算机科学教育，读了研究生，这可能
little less standard and did some some great work with i thought great work with anna carlin who's this person who works at these are intersection of theory and systems work and got a little bit of a taste for both you know thinking about things for long enough that they make, but also trying to get your head around whether the thing that you've thought about should actually be turned into something that computers do. It actually results in something meaningful and of consequence. From there, I went to actually start working at Microsoft's research lab in Silicon Valley, which was there for 12 years or something like this. Lots of great people. This is very formative. This is a lot of really interesting combination of theoretical computer
稍微不那么标准，并且做了一些很棒的工作，我认为是与 Anna Karlin 一起做的，她是一位在理论和系统交叉领域工作的人。我从中体会到了两者的乐趣，既要思考足够长的时间让想法成熟，也要努力弄清楚你思考的东西是否真的应该转化为计算机能做的事情。它是否真的能产生有意义和有价值的结果。从那里，我开始在微软硅谷研究院工作，我在那里待了 12 年左右。那里有很多很棒的人。这非常有启发性。这是一个理论计算机科学家和系统研究人员之间非常有趣的结合，原则上是分布式系统，但本质上是计算机系统。这是一个真正学到很多东西的好地方。那里的人非常强大。你既学到了计算机科学的实际技术细节，也学到了如何思考研究，如何做有价值的事情。你从那种快节奏发表论文的学术压力中解脱出来，可以等到你真正认为事情做对了再告诉别人。是的。MSR 硅谷研究院关闭时你在那里吗？我在。天哪，那真是让我心碎。我的意思是，我读到关于它的消息时，我完全……
scientists and people working on systems, in principle distributed systems, but computer systems. And a great place to really learn a lot. The people there were very strong. And you learn a lot both about the actual technical bits of computer science, but also how to think about research, how to do things of consequence. You're relieved a bit from a bunch of the academic pressures of publishing at a very fast cadence and sort of wait until you've actually got the thing that you think is right before telling people about it. Yeah. Were you there when MSR in Silicon Valley closed down? I was. Oh man, that broke my heart. I mean, I read about it in that I'm totally happy.
我必须小心措辞，但那是一个非常舒适的地方。我确实有点喜欢人们偶尔走出舒适区，去尝试新的、有趣的、不同的事情的想法。我很高兴我被迫走出了舒适区，因为我觉得那之后的时间，至少对我来说，非常好。我得以做新的事情，思考新的东西，尝试我如果一直待在那里就不会去做的看待世界的方式。我本来会一直待在那里再过 12 年，
I have to be careful framing this, but like it was a very comfortable place. And I do kind of like the idea that folks get moved out of their comfort zone occasionally and have to go and do new and interesting and different things. And I was very happy that I was moved out of my comfort zone because I feel like the time after that was, for me at least, was very good. I got to do new things, think about new stuff, try different ways to the world that I wouldn't have bothered to do if I had still been around. I would have just stayed there for another 12 years
开启自动驾驶模式，写论文，做同样的事情。所以我个人很高兴我被稍微震动了一下，尽管我有很多同事并不那么高兴。是的，我的意思是，我处于类似的位置，我有一份工作……有很多同事并不那么高兴，但是的，我的意思是，我处于类似的位置，我有一份工作，你知道，非常……那是一份非常舒适的工作，我得到了不错的评价，而且……在这种情况下，你知道，我没有……我选择了抓住这个
on autopilot, writing papers, doing things. So I'm personally glad that I got shaken up a bit by that, though I have lots of colleagues who weren't nearly as glad. Yeah, I mean, I was in a similar position where I had a job that was very, have lots of colleagues who weren't nearly as glad but yeah I mean I was in a similar position where I was had a job that I was you know very it was a very comfortable job and I was getting kind of good ratings and um and I had a in this case you know I didn't I wasn't I chose to take this
机会，但离开舒适区总是让人感到非常紧张，因为你觉得我可能再也回不去了，而且……你知道，这是一种巨大的冒险。但是，你知道，我从我的经历中学到了两件事，我很想听听你从你的经历中学到了什么。我学到的第一点是，无论你在当前公司投入了多少时间和精力，无论你多么深入地参与了流程，当你离开时，其他人都会接手，而且……你知道，我其实以为团队会比实际情况挣扎得多，但他们做得很好。另一件事是，反过来，你知道，你总是可以回去的，而且……人们，
opportunity but I was always kind of you're always kind of really nervous leaving your comfort zone because you feel like I can never really go back and and uh you know and kind of really nervous leaving your comfort zone because you feel like i can never really go back and and uh you know and kind of taking this big risk um but you know there's two things that i kind of learned from from my experience and i'd love to hear what you learned from yours for mine i learned one is that no matter how kind of much time and energy you've put and how much you're part of the process at your current company that when you leave everyone else just picks up the slack and like you know you i actually thought that is the team was going to struggle a lot more than they actually did they were just fine and the other thing is going the other direction you know you can always go back and uh people you
如果你告诉你的老板你要离开的原因，前提是保持良好的关系，他们总是很乐意欢迎你回来。所以这两点都让我感觉好多了。现在，显然在 MSR 的案例中，没有“回去”这回事，但我从其他公司的人那里了解到，对于努力工作的人才来说，总是有很好的机会。
know if you tell your boss you're leaving and why you're leaving, provide it's on good terms and everything, they're always happy to welcome you back. And so both of those made me feel a lot better. Now, obviously in the MSR case, there was a going back, but I know from someone who saw that from another company that there's always really good opportunities
我认为那是完全正确的。我的意思是，这也是我的经历，即从机械的角度来看，当时要回到微软是很困难的，基于事情发生的方式。但如果你，
for good people who work hard. I think that's totally right. I mean, those, my experience as well, which is that mechanically it would have been difficult to go back to Microsoft at the time based on how things happened. But if you're,
你知道，如果你擅长你所做的事情，或者足够接近，那么对于许多不同的人来说，外面有很多机会。老实说，在创业领域也出现了很多机会，我们 Materialize 团队一直在与人们进行这些对话，老实说，在创业领域，我们一直在与人们进行这些对话。我们试图
you know, if you're good at what you do or close enough, there, there's lots of opportunities out there for a lot of different folks. There shows up a bunch to be totally honest in the startup space as well, where we just have materialized, continually have these conversations with people that we're, to be totally honest, in the startup space as well, where we just have materialized, continually have these conversations with people. We're trying to
招募那些在某处有舒适工作、但对风险有点担心的优秀人才，对吧？风险在于，嗯，我想离开我的工作去尝试一些风险更大的事情吗？如果最坏的情况发生了怎么办？答案通常是，嗯，最坏的情况就是你回到你原来的工作或类似的工作。并不是说他们会因为你想去尝试一些有趣的事情而对你怀恨在心。通常，他们非常欢迎你回来，或者，你知道，如果由于某种原因你的机会消失了，去另一家公司做类似的事情。这是一件我事先肯定没想到的事情。我当时想，哇，这里真的很舒服。确实，如果我去别的地方，再得到这样的机会会很棘手。但这并不一定是真的。是的，有道理。我听说在创业世界里，你知道，有……
recruit great people who have a cushy job somewhere and are a bit worried about the risk, right? The risk of like, well, do I want to leave my job to do something that's a little riskier? What happens if in the worst case scenario? And the answer is usually, well, the worst case scenario is you just go back to your existing job or something similar. It's not like they're not going to be at your throat just because you wanted to go off and do something interesting. Generally, they're super welcome to either have you back or, you know, doing a similar thing at a different company if for any particular reason your opportunity is gone. So it's a thing that you don't, I certainly didn't think of ahead of time. I thought like, wow, it's really comfortable here. And indeed, if I go somewhere else, it's gonna be tricky to get this again. And it doesn't, it's not necessarily the case. Yeah, that makes sense. I've heard that in the startup world, you know, there's,
是的，这是一个很好的观点。在创业世界里，保护感较少。例如，如果你在一家初创公司，公司转型了，他们不再需要你的特定技能，那么你可能会被解雇。而在一家大公司，几乎总有你可以去的地方，或者他们会给你时间去重新学习。所以这会让人们感到紧张，但同样的道理依然适用，即总是有大量的需求。所以如果你找到一家你真正热衷的初创公司，你知道，你可以充满信心地加入它。
yeah, it's a really good point. In the startup world, there's a sense less protection. Like, for example, if you're at a startup and the startup pivots and they just don't need your particular skill anymore, then you could, you know, be let go for that. Whereas if you're in some giant company, there's almost like always someplace you can go or they'll give you time to retool. And so that can make people nervous, but the same thing still applies that, that, that there's always kind of a, you know, a ton of demand there. And so if you find some startup that's doing something you're really passionate about, you know, you can, you can join it with, with confidence.
我认为那是对的。我的意思是，这确实是我所看到的。而且，这可能确实来自一种特权地位，但事实确实是，虽然初创公司可能会做一些令人惊讶的事情，导致你决定不再喜欢他们，或者可能只是不合适。那是坏消息。但目前，更大的世界仍然对计算机科学家非常兴奋，尤其是那些正在做大胆、创新、创业型事情的人。通常，公司很乐意与你联系并为你找到事情做。是的，有道理。所以你在 MSR，然后你是从那里去了另一家大公司，还是直接跳进了创业世界？
I think that's right. I mean, that's certainly been what I've seen. And I, that might be coming from a position of privilege for sure, but it's certainly the case that although a startup might do something surprising and you decide you don't like them anymore, or maybe it just doesn't fit. And that's bad news. The larger world is at the moment still really excited for computer scientists, especially ones who are doing bold, innovative startup-y things. Usually companies are pretty happy to get in touch and find something for you to do. Yeah, that makes sense. So you were at MSR and then did you go from there to another big company or did you jump straight into the startup world?
是的，没有。实际上，我做的是在微软工作的 12 年里我没有休过任何假。没有实质性的假期。等等，不会吧？你是认真的吗？我在一两年前休过一次，大概三周。但除此之外，都是，你知道，假期去探亲之类的事情。没有特别实质性的假期。
Yeah, no. Actually, what I did is I hadn't taken any vacation in the 12 years I had been at Microsoft. No vacation of consequence. Wait, no way. Are you serious? I had taken one like a year or two before I took about three weeks off. But other than that, it was all, you know, visit folks for the holidays type things. No particular vacations of consequence.
你的假期会累积吗？那是怎么运作的？有限制吗？我的意思是，这是加州，所以他们不允许……你知道，它会累积，但上限是六周左右。所以你只是达到了上限。你多年来一直在浪费假期。这太疯狂了。
Did your vacation accumulate? How did that work? Is there a limit? I mean, it's California, so they're not allowed to. It's, you know, it builds up, but it maxes out at some six weeks or something like that. And so you just had maxed out. You're just shedding vacation days for years. That's wild.
我的意思是，你一定对你所做的事情非常热衷。不，我的意思是，是的，也许吧，但不是。我当时在生活中肯定还没有建立起良好的工作与生活平衡、可持续性之类的概念。它只是……是的，其实我们应该做一期关于这个的节目。
I mean, you must be really passionate about what you're doing. No, I mean, yeah, maybe, but no. It was much, I certainly hadn't at that point in my life come across building up a good work-life balance and sustainability and stuff like that. It just- Yeah, actually, we should do a show on that.
也许我们会邀请你。我们会邀请你来谈谈工作。我不认为人们想要我的建议。我们从未涵盖过这一点。现在你提到了，这非常、非常重要。这很容易就能聊满一整小时。我认为过去这一年让这一点变得非常清楚。我们在公司里有很多员工
Maybe we'll invite you. We'll invite you to talk about work. I don't think people want my advice. We never covered that. And now that you mention it, that's so, so important. It could easily be a whole hour. This past year has made that really clear, I think. We've had a lot of folks at the company
因为非标准的原因而感到焦虑和压力，这让这一点变得非常清楚。我想，我们公司有很多员工，你知道，因为非标准的原因而感到焦虑和压力，对吧？不是你预料到的事情，不是你会在日历上标记为“确保放松”的事情。对我们来说，尝试关注这一点，提醒人们，
that are just getting wound up and stressed for non-standard reasons, It's made that really clear. I think like a lot of, we've had a lot of folks at the company that, you know, just getting wound up and stressed for nonstandard reasons, right? Like not things you would have anticipated, not things that you sort of put on your calendar as make sure to, to unwind. And it's been really important for us to try to pay attention, remind people that like,
你应该绝对考虑休假，这非常重要。不要因为你不能去某个岛上喝着色彩鲜艳的饮料而感到焦虑，是的，花点时间，是的。你知道，当人们接近 PTO（带薪休假）上限时，我会收到这些自动邮件，而且……你知道，通常，我的意思是，我甚至不认为我以前见过它们，但现在每个人都达到了上限。我认为你一针见血地指出了，
you should absolutely think about taking time off. Don't sweat the fact that you can't go to an Island somewhere and, and drink, you know bright colored drinks yeah take some time yeah you know i i get these automated emails from uh when people get close to their limit on on pto um and uh you know usually i mean i've never even i don't think i've ever seen them before but now everyone is at their limit and and i think you hit the nail on the head,
人们说，好吧，你知道，如果我只能待在家里，我不想休假。但随后他们就完全精疲力竭了。所以你几乎必须强迫人们说，看，你需要花一周时间只是待在家里什么都不做，因为你只是在为一些无关紧要的事情抓狂。是的，这是一个极其困难的时期。所以你问，你在微软之后做了什么？这就是过渡到这里的原因。但基本上发生的事情是，我决定我应该休个假，消失到摩洛哥
people say, well, you know, I don't want to go on PTO if I'm just gonna have to stay around the house. But then they're completely burnt out. And so you almost have to kind of force people and say, look, you need to spend a week just sitting around your house doing nothing like you just have to because you are just flipping out over stuff that doesn't matter. And yes, this is an incredibly difficult time for that. So you had asked, what did you do after Microsoft? And that was the segue into here. But what happened essentially was I concluded I should take some vacation and vanish to Morocco
去冲浪一会儿。冲浪和瑜伽，之类的东西，只是放松一下。实际上非常愉快。即使算上冲浪、一日三餐和瑜伽，也比旧金山的生活成本低。所以这很棒。我开始过一种更“低保真”的生活，我想，比如不用穿那么多衣服。
for a little bit for some surfing. Surfing and yoga, stuff like that, and just chilling out. It was actually really pleasant. It was, even with the surfing and the three meals a day and yoga, it was a rent reduction from San Francisco. So that was pretty sweet. And just started doing a bit more of like lo-fi living, I guess, like not wearing quite so much.
我有一台笔记本电脑，一个手提箱，里面装着我几乎所有的东西，然后四处游荡。我在欧洲有一些工作义务。我同意主持一些研讨会，所以，你知道，做了一点工作，但大部分时间只是……闲逛，顺便做点工作，但按照我自己的节奏。是的，那太好了。我不知道你是否了解理查德·斯托曼（Richard Stallman）的生活方式，但这听起来很像……我前段时间采访过理查德·斯托曼。他基本上是从一个会议到另一个会议，发表演讲，
I had a laptop, had one suitcase that was everything that I'd owned pretty much and sort of wandered a bit around. I had some work obligations in Europe. I had agreed to chair, uh, some workshops and so, you know, did a little bit of work, but mostly just, uh, slumming around doing, doing some work on the side, but at my own pace. Yeah. That's, that's super nice. I don't know if you know, uh, Richard Stallman's lifestyle, but this sounds a lot like... I interviewed Richard Stallman a while ago. He basically goes conference to conference, gives talks,
他会问，我能睡在你的沙发上吗？他有一个电子邮件列表，上面列出了所有他可以睡的沙发。他只是从一个地方到另一个地方结识新朋友。这听起来是一种非常、非常令人兴奋的生活，既令人兴奋，又很放松，这很难得。这绝对很有趣。所以，有一段时间是，是的，
and he asks, can I sleep on your couch? He has this email thread, list serve type thing of all the couches he can sleep on. And he just goes from place to place meeting new people. And it sounds like a really, really kind of exciting, you know, kind of life where it's exciting, but it's also chill, which is kind of hard to get. It definitely was interesting. Like, so some of the time was going, yes,
当然有一些闲逛、冲浪和摩洛哥之类的事情，但也有去柏林拜访做 Apache Flink 的人，去英国剑桥与他们合作几周。然后最终，去苏黎世联邦理工学院（ETH）拜访，他们碰巧在做一堆相关的工作，关于数据流处理的工作。他们正在研究构建能够从数据中心提取“废气”的系统。所以，无论你的数据中心发生了什么，不是正在进行的实际工作，而是发送了什么消息，谁在与谁通信，你的各个机架之间发生了什么，并将这些输入到他们试图构建的某种分析子系统中。
there's of course some just hanging out and surfing and Rocco type things, but there's also dropping in on the people doing Apache Flink in Berlin and dropping in at Cambridge in the UK to work with them for a few weeks. And then eventually it turns out dropping in on ETH in Zurich, which happened to be doing a bunch of related work stuff, work on data flow processing. They were looking at building systems that would essentially take the exhaust out of data centers. So whatever's happening in your data center, not the actual work that's going on, but what messages are getting sent around, who's communicating with whom, what was going on between your various racks, and feed that into some sort of analysis subsystem they're trying to build.
作为一个技术过渡，这是他们努力让 Spark 工作的一个时刻。他们已经让 Nyad（我们在 MSR 所做的）运行起来了，但他们是在 Linux 上，而当时 Linux 对 C# 的支持并不出色。所以负责人 Mothy Roscoe 基本上说，看，你为什么不直接过来帮我们解决这个问题呢？因为这听起来正是你一直声称你的东西擅长的，我们确实需要它，我们可以付钱给你，而且你在欧洲。瑞士很不错，所以去做吧。
And just as a technical segue, this is a moment where they were struggling to make, for example, Spark work. They had gotten Nyad, which is what we had done at MSR, up and working, but they're on Linux and the C-sharp support on Linux at the time was not stellar. So the guy in charge, Mothy Roscoe basically said, look, why don't you just show up and help us sort this out? Because this sounds like it's exactly what you've been claiming your stuff is good at, and we could really use it, and we can pay you, and you're in Europe. And Switzerland's nice, so go for it.
所以这导致了与他们的一些持续合作。我在那里工作了大约七个月。所以，为了确保我理解，你是让 Spark 工作了，还是你让微软的那个东西工作了？哦，我什么都没让它工作。抱歉。他们已经在尝试了，他们知道他们想构建什么，本质上，
So that led to some recurring collaboration with them. So I worked there for about seven months. So just so I understand, so you got Spark to work or you got this thing from Microsoft? Oh, I didn't get anything to work. Sorry. They were already trying to, they knew what they wanted to build, essentially,
他们想做的分析类型。他们尝试用 Spark 来做。但不幸的是，Spark 当时正在落后。它无法跟上数据量。啊，我明白了。来自微软研究院的工作，那些导致这种实时流处理工作（及时数据流等）的东西，最初在微软是一个名为 Naiad 的项目，那是一个 C# 项目，在 Windows 上运行得很好，在 Linux 上也能运行，但是……那个怎么拼写？是 N-Y-A-D 吗？哦，不，N-A-I-A-D。哦，NIAID，好的。
like sorts of analysis they wanted to do. And they had tried to do that with Spark. And Spark, unfortunately, at the time was just falling behind. It couldn't keep up with the data volumes. Ah, I see. The work from Microsoft Research, the stuff that led into this real-time streaming work timely data flow and stuff like that was originally at microsoft this project called niad that was a c-sharp project and worked great on windows and worked on on linux but um how do you spell that? It's N-Y-A-D? Oh, no, N-A-I-A-D. Oh, NIAID, okay.
它是希腊语。Naiads 是河流、溪流和流动水的动画精灵。哦，那说得通。有一个大数据项目叫 Dryad。是的，是的，同一群人。哦，有趣。好的，那么 Dryad 是 Naiad 的进化版吗？不，恰恰相反，尽管“进化”这个词可能有点夸张。所以 Dryad 肯定先出现。
It's Greek. The NIAIDs were the animating spirits of rivers and streams and flowing water. Oh, that makes sense. There was a big data project called DRIAD. Yes, yep, the same group of people. Oh, interesting. Okay, so is DRIad like an evolution of 9? No, it's the other way around, though evolution is maybe a bit strong. So Dryad certainly came first.
Dryad 在 MapReduce 流行起来之后出现，Dryad 基本上说，为什么不考虑更大的数据流图，但仍然使用大致相同的原则？所以 Dryads 是树木和森林的动画精灵。是的，是的。这就是它的来源，构建某种树木和森林的动画精灵。是的，是的。这就是它的来源，构建某种
Dryad sort of came to be after MapReduce rose in popularity, and Dryad essentially said, why not think about larger data flow graphs, but still use roughly the same principles? So Dryads are the animating spirits of trees and forests. Yep, yep. That's where that came from, building sort animating spirits of trees and forests. Yep. Yep. That's where that came from, building sort of DAGs of data flow graphs. But it's still very much in the spirit of batch computation. So this data flow graph runs by looking at its
数据流图的 DAG（有向无环图）。但它仍然非常具有批处理计算的精神。所以这个数据流图通过查看它的
inputs, which are probably very large data sets, turning on the bits of work nearest those data sets, running them to completion. They produce output data, you start up the next people. Yeah. So I mean, maybe just to give. They produce output data, you start up the next people. Yeah, so I mean, maybe just to give a bit of context here, like people know about, let's say, let's see an example here, like MP3s, where you have to kind of encode something in an MP3. And so you wouldn't necessarily have some incremental MP3.
输入（可能是非常大的数据集）来运行，开启最接近这些数据集的工作位，运行它们直到完成。它们产生输出数据，你启动下一个人。是的。所以，我的意思是，也许只是为了提供一点背景，人们知道，比如，让我们看一个例子，比如 MP3，你必须在 MP3 中编码某些东西。所以你不会一定有某种增量 MP3。
Like most MP3s are, you know, there's some sort of bookkeeping and some stuff built into the file. And it might be random access, but there's usually some kind of paging. So it's not totally random access. And so you end up with like this kind of big volume that's effectively immutable. If you want to mutate it, then you would run it through a process that produces another big volume that's slightly different. And so this is kind of the essence of MapReduce, or let's say batch processing.
大多数 MP3 是，你知道，文件里内置了一些簿记和一些东西。它可能是随机访问的，但通常有一些分页。所以它不是完全随机访问的。所以你最终得到的是这种实际上不可变的巨大卷。如果你想改变它，那么你会通过一个产生另一个略有不同的巨大卷的过程来运行它。所以这就是 MapReduce 或批处理的本质。
So you can take this, you can break it up based on how the data is chunked so let's say the data is is separated in chunks such that you have a thousand chunks and at most you can have a thousand machines um uh you're reading in a chunk doing something to it and then emitting um another another set of chunks um now those chunks get you know sh. That's a shuffle part of MapReduce. And then the shuffled chunks end up in buckets. And then those buckets can be processed a second time. And the output of all of this is just another huge batch of data. Spark and other things are kind of built on the idea of MapReduce. And there's a lot of also cosmetic things built on MapReduce. Like there's Apache Crunch, which was kind of a, you know,
所以你可以根据数据的分块方式来拆分它，假设数据被分成一千个块，你最多可以有一千台机器，你正在读取一个块，对它做一些事情，然后发出另一组块。现在这些块被，你知道，洗牌。那是 MapReduce 的洗牌部分。然后洗牌后的块进入桶中。然后这些桶可以被第二次处理。所有这些的输出只是另一大批数据。Spark 和其他东西是建立在 MapReduce 的思想之上的。而且 MapReduce 上面还有很多装饰性的东西。比如 Apache Crunch，它是一种
something that sat on top of MapReduce and just made it more accessible. But one thing that's not really clear is how do you handle like a fire hose? Like if you have something that's a machine that's generating logs incrementally, you know, one a second or something, well then this idea kind of doesn't fit that paradigm. And that's where the real-time streaming is really important. And actually, your example of MP3s is pretty good. I don't want to pretend to know a great deal about how MP3s are encoded, but you could totally imagine, we've been talking now for almost half an hour, and we could record all of that and plop
坐在 MapReduce 之上的东西，只是让它更容易访问。但有一件事不是很清楚，那就是你如何处理像消防水管一样的数据？如果你有一台机器在增量地生成日志，你知道，每秒一个之类的，那么这个想法就不太适合那种范式。这就是实时流处理非常重要的地方。实际上，你的 MP3 例子很好。我不想假装非常了解 MP3 是如何编码的，但你完全可以想象，我们现在已经谈了快半个小时了，我们可以记录所有这些并把它扔进一个文件，然后让某人拿起它并开始编码过程。但同样合理的是，当我们产生数据时，某人可以拿起这些数据并开始转换和编码的过程。这样当我们完成时，计算也几乎完成了，准备好分发了。或者，例如，如果有人在听，他们可以在近乎实时的情况下拿起编码过程的输出，这比原始波形文件更有效，而不必像这些批处理计算那样等待整个会话。它只是分阶段处理得略有不同。所以，与其一次性完成所有第一步工作并等待直到完成，你可以开始第一步，无论那是什么，并开始产生部分结果。然后无论第二步是什么，它也可以同时开始工作。你只是让事情保持忙碌，否则它们就会在等待。所以否则
it down in a file and then have someone pick that up and start the encoding process. But it's just as reasonable to imagine that as we've been producing data, someone could be picking that data up and start the process of transforming it and encoding it. So that by the time we're done, the computation is also pretty nearly done and ready to disseminate. Or for example, if people were listening, they could in near real time be picking up the output of the encoding process, something more efficient than just the raw wave file, and not have to wait for the entire session as these batch computations. It's just done staged slightly differently. So instead of doing all of that first work at once and waiting until you're done, you can start the first step, whatever that happens to be, and start producing partial results. And then whatever the second step is, that can also start working at the same time. And you just sort of keep things busy where they would otherwise be waiting. So otherwise
每个人都在等待那第一个小时的数据完成，然后才能开始工作。与其那样做，不如直接让所有事情同时进行。这肯定需要更多的簿记。但我认为好的一点是，从用户的角度来看，他们不一定需要考虑新的习惯用语。系统本身可以改变它的行为。它突然变得比以前更灵敏了。
everyone's just waiting for that first hour of data to be finished before they can even start working. And rather than do that, no, you just get everything going all at once. It's a bit more bookkeeping, for sure. But the nice thing, I think, is that potentially from the user's point of view, they don't need to think of new idioms necessarily. The system itself can just change its behavior. And it just is suddenly a bit more responsive than it was previously.
你不需要教育用户告诉他们你必须编写一个新程序。所以如果你能利用人们对“我如何处理大数据”的心理模型，而不必将其改变为某种全新的、完全不同的处理数据的方式，那可能非常强大。是的，完全说得通。我认为，是的，从功能角度来看，流处理就像一个超集，对吧？因为你总是可以流式传输一批数据。但就你能做的事情而言，我肯定有一些限制，比如你不能一直随机访问整个数据集。所以，你知道，有些事情你不能用流处理来做。
You don't need to educate the user to tell them you must write a new program. So that's potentially really powerful if you can harness people's mental model for how do I approach working with big data and not have to change that to be some new, totally different way of working with data. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I think that, yeah, streaming from a functionality standpoint is like a superset, right? Because you can always stream in a batch of data. But then in terms of what you can do, I'm sure there's some limits, like you don't have random access to the entire data set all the time. And so, you know, there's some things that you can't do with streaming.
或者如果你打算做它们，你必须积累某种簿记，而不是一次性完成。我想我接触数据流处理最接近的，或者说我能想象到的数据流处理的问题，是通过 Presto。所以 Presto 是这个 SQL 引擎。它不是实时的，但它把所有东西都放在内存里。正因为如此，它非常快。但正因为如此，一旦你内存不足，它就放弃了。所以，例如，如果你想，如果你有一个巨大的数据库，大小甚至不重要，你只想看看你的名字在数据库中出现了多少次，Presto 可以做到，因为它可以读取
Or if you are going to do them, you have to accumulate some kind of bookkeeping versus just doing it in one shot. I think the closest I've come to data streaming is, or with the issues, let's say I can imagine coming up with data streaming is through Presto. So Presto is this SQL engine. It's not for real time, but it keeps everything in memory. And so because of that, it's really fast. But because of that, as soon as you run out of memory, it just gives up. And so for example, if you wanted to, if you have a giant database, it doesn't even matter the size and you want to just see how many times your name shows up in the database, Presto can do that because it can read
一次少至一行，寻找你的名字，然后保持计数。但如果你想做一些事情，比如生成名字的直方图，或者也许更好的例子是，如果你想将表连接到它自身，以便相同名字的所有行都被分组在一起，那么 Presto 必须以某种方式将整个数据库保留在内存中来执行该自连接。而且 Presto 很可能会崩溃。所以同样的限制也适用于这里，你不想处于需要一次性获取整个数据集的情况。是的，我的意思是，你没说错。我认为流处理所做的事情之一是开始暴露一些限制，本质上。正如你所说，你可以将批处理计算视为流
as little as one row at a time, look for your name, and then just keep a count. But if you wanted to do something like generate a histogram of names, then, or maybe a better example is if you wanted to join the table to itself so that all of the rows for the same name were grouped together, well, then Presto has to keep the entire database in memory in some way, shape, or form to do that self-join. And most likely Presto will just blow up. And so the same limitations there apply here where you don't want to be in a situation where you need the entire data set at one time. Yeah, I mean, you're not wrong. One of the things I suppose that streaming does is start to expose some limitations, essentially. As you say, you can look at a batch computation just as a streaming
计算。当然，从 HDFS 或磁盘或任何地方读取数据的过程并不是原子地加载到内存中。它很可能是顺序地查看数据。所以它已经在从你的硬件中流式传输。所以它已经是一种流计算了。但一旦你给人们流处理系统并告诉他们，哦，低延迟，等等等等，他们就开始相信这一点。他们开始使用它。当他们做这样的事情时，如果他们的计算机着火了，他们会感到惊讶。是的，有道理。所以我们开始看到 Materialize 是如何“物化”的，对吧？所以你当时在 ETH 与 NIAID 合作。你正在帮助他们处理那个。
computation. And of course, the process reading the data off of HDFS or off of your disk or whatever is not loading it atomically into memory. It's looking sequentially, most likely, at the data. So it's sort of streaming in off of your hardware. So it's a type of streaming computation already. But as soon as you give people streaming systems and tell them, ooh, low latency, something, something, something, they start to believe that. They start to use it. And they start to be surprised if their computer catches on fire when you do something like this. Yeah, that makes sense. So we're starting to see how Materialize got materialized, right? So you were working with ETH on NIAID. You're helping them kind of with that.
你是否看到了导致你开始 Materialize 的许多问题？有一点。我不会说直接，没有。导致你开始 Materialize？有一点。我不会说直接，没有。让我们看看。所以我只是要把时钟稍微拨回一点，这样我就能避免在未来绊倒自己。我离开微软研究院时发生的事情之一是，我们不再打算与微软有联系。
And did you kind of see a lot of the issues that led you to start Materialize? A little bit. I wouldn't say directly, no. led you to start Materialize? A little bit. I wouldn't say directly, no. Let's see. So I'm just going to roll back the clock just a little bit so that I avoid tripping myself up in the future. One of the things that happened as I departed Microsoft Research is that we were no longer meant to be affiliated with Microsoft.
我们不再，特别是，不再在 NIAID 代码库上工作。感觉是时候学习一种新的编程语言了。所以我当时从 C# 转到了 Rust，基本上开始对那个项目进行重启。所以是一个不同版本的 NIAID，修复了我们第一次遇到的一些问题，而且几乎肯定没有在所有维度上都走得那么远，但开始成为现在这个 Rust 中的“及时数据流”（timely data flow）项目，这实际上是我去 ETH 并与他们合作的项目。我想说，在 ETH，这是一个学术环境，你有更多的
We were no longer, in particular, no longer working on the NIAID code base. And it felt like a good time to pick up a new programming language. So I pivoted over from C Sharp to Rust at the time and started essentially doing a reboot of that project. So a different version of NIAID that fixed some of the issues that we had the first time around and almost certainly didn't quite get as far in all the dimensions, but started being what is now this timely data flow in Rust project, which is actually what I went to ETH with and worked with them on there. I would say that at ETH, this is an academic setting and you have a lot more
自由。所以学术界和 Materialize 之间的一个大区别，我们稍后会谈到，但在学术界，你有更多的自由去做你想做和需要做的事情。所以从某种意义上说，他们是技术的消费者，所以他们可以构建定制的技术片段，这些片段可以工作，因为作为一群计算机科学博士，他们都有权编写一堆新代码并说，太棒了，对我们有效，发布吧。相比之下，Materialize 则完全相反。我们，构建 Materialize 的人拥有这些技能，但目标是针对那些不想接受流数据流基础设施高级教育的用户。
liberties. So one of the big distinctions between academia and materialized we'll get to, but in academia, you have a lot more liberty to just do what you want and what you need. So in a sense, they were acting as the consumer of the technology, so they could just build bespoke pieces of technology that would just work because as a bunch of computer science PhD people, they're all empowered to just write a whole pile of new code and say, great, works for us, ship it. And Materialize by contrast is very much the opposite. We, the people building Materialize have these skills, but the goal is to target people, users who don't want to have to get an advanced education in streaming data flow infrastructure or anything like that.
自由。学术界和Materialize之间的一个重大区别我们稍后会谈到，但在学术界，你有更多的自由去做你想做和需要做的事情。从某种意义上说，他们充当了技术的消费者，所以他们可以构建定制的技术组件，这些组件可以直接运行，因为作为一群计算机科学博士，他们都有能力编写大量新代码，并说：太棒了，这对我们有效，发布吧。相比之下，Materialize则完全相反。我们这些构建Materialize的人确实具备这些技能，但我们的目标是针对那些不想在流数据流基础设施或其他类似领域接受高等教育的用户。
The goal is very much to take the ideas, the things that were learned along the way, essentially, and try to map them to concepts and idioms that a lot more people are already familiar with. In the case of Materialize, that's SQL, which is a language that doesn't say anything about streaming or any of that stuff, but does have sufficient concepts, things like joins and views and indexes and reductions that you can allow people to express queries and ideas in that programming language and then transport them. We do the hard work to do this, but transport them to streaming infrastructure. Oh, interesting. That makes a ton of sense. Yeah, there's a lot to unpack there. So yeah, I guess since we're on that topic, how do you prevent people from doing things in SQL that would just cause a lot of Harper and trying to join a table to itself, for example? Yeah, so we don't. Okay. I think
我们的目标很大程度上是把这些想法，以及一路学到的东西，本质上映射到更多人已经熟悉的各种概念和习语中。就 Materialize 而言，这就是 SQL。它是一种对流处理或其他任何东西只字不提的语言，但它拥有足够的概念，比如连接（joins）、视图（views）、索引（indexes）和归约（reductions），你可以让人们用这种编程语言来表达查询和想法，然后将它们迁移过去。我们做了艰苦的工作来实现这一点，将它们迁移到流式基础设施上。哦，有意思。这非常有道理。是的，这里面有很多东西需要拆解。所以，既然我们谈到了这个话题，你如何防止人们在 SQL 中做一些会导致大量麻烦的事情，比如试图将一个表与它自身进行连接？是的，我们不阻止。好的。我想
that's sort of fair to say, like the, it feels a little bit like databases back from the nineties or something like that, where you could, with a crappy query, take down, you know, your production database. If, if you go and try to do something that's a cross join or something like that. Yeah, that makes sense. But with, you know, the right window size, I don't know if that's in ANSI SQL or if it's only in Presto, but yeah, there's this whole, we have this thing where we do a self join, but the where clause is such
这样说比较公平，感觉有点像九十年代的数据库，如果你写了一个糟糕的查询，可能会搞垮你的生产数据库。如果你去尝试做交叉连接（cross join）之类的操作。是的，这很有道理。但是，你知道，使用合适的窗口大小，我不知道这是否在 ANSI SQL 中，还是只在 Presto 中，但确实有这种情况，我们有一种做法是进行自连接（self join），但 where 子句是这样的
that we can do it within a window. Like if we sort, basically sort the database, although sorting, I think in streaming would also be a challenge. Yes, some of these joins, I think, But I think the streaming doesn't have to do everything. It just has to do some of the things that need to be done in real time. And so it's a good complement to something like Presto or Spark. Yeah. So for example, you brought up one of the main pain points, to be honest, with SQL streaming, which is window functions in SQL.
以至于我们可以在一个窗口内完成它。比如如果我们对数据库进行排序，尽管我认为在流处理中排序也是一个挑战。是的，其中一些连接，我想，但我认为流处理不必做所有事情。它只需要做一些需要实时完成的事情。所以它是像 Presto 或 Spark 这样的工具的良好补充。是的。例如，老实说，你提到了 SQL 流处理的主要痛点之一，那就是 SQL 中的窗口函数。
And for folks not familiar, window functions in SQL are roughly a way to write in SQL the equivalent of a for loop. It's just sort of you can say, put these records together and now attach to each record its ordinal position in this list, like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, whatever. And you can write queries that are really problematic. Like you could say, yeah, do this and then get me all of the odd records out. And that's a query.
对于不熟悉的人来说，SQL 中的窗口函数大致是一种用 SQL 编写 for 循环等效代码的方法。你只需要说，把这些记录放在一起，现在给每条记录附加它在这个列表中的序号位置，比如 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 等等。你可以写出非常有问题的查询。比如你可以说，做这个，然后把所有奇数记录给我。这就是一个查询。
You can write it. It's a little mysterious, but you can totally write this. And it's very problematic if someone adds one record to the beginning of this list, right? Because all of the answers change and not just slightly change. The entire set of data flip-flops each time you add one new record. And it's just very problematic in terms of performance and resources for that query. And it's a good question. Should you work hard to prevent people from writing these queries? Should you let them write them and learn that their performance isn't good? Some of the queries are fine, right? If instead of saying, give me odd versus even records, you say, just give me the top five, it doesn't flip-flop nearly as much. You can add one record,
你可以写出来。它有点神秘，但你完全可以写出来。如果有人在这个列表的开头添加了一条记录，那就非常成问题了，对吧？因为所有的答案都变了，而且不仅仅是轻微的变化。每次你添加一条新记录，整个数据集都会翻转。对于该查询的性能和资源而言，这非常成问题。这是一个好问题。你应该努力阻止人们编写这些查询吗？你应该让他们写出来，然后发现它们的性能不好吗？有些查询没问题，对吧？如果不是说给我奇数和偶数记录，而是说只给我前五名，它就不会翻转得那么厉害。你可以添加一条记录，
and the worst you can do is bump someone out of the top five. But it's a great question. And really, this is the heart of what a lot of the big data problems out there have been. How do I figure out how to present an API to users that these are like handles to scissors? Like, how do you present handles that you can grab safely? You don't grab the cutting part of the scissors. You only grab the safe part.
最坏的情况也就是把某人挤出前五名。但这是一个很好的问题。这确实是许多大数据问题的核心所在。我该如何向用户提供一个 API，让这些东西就像剪刀的把手一样？比如，你如何提供可以安全抓取的把手？你不会去抓剪刀的刀刃部分。你只会抓安全的部分。
So it's a tool that you can pick up and only use safely. How do you do that? We know how to give people access to computers from EC2. You can just check them out, write whatever code you want, and cause the computers to be arbitrarily problematic. That's easy. We know how to give people access to computers. How do you give them gloves that they can wear to access the computers safely and effectively? And sometimes that means telling people no, that's sort of where this, the essence of a lot of these big data design questions are, is like, how do you prevent people from, you know, I guess, give them enough rope to be useful, but not so much that they can get themselves into trouble. Yeah, yeah, that makes
所以这是一个你可以拿起来并且只能安全使用的工具。你该怎么做？我们知道如何通过 EC2 给人们提供计算机访问权限。你可以直接租用它们，编写任何你想要的代码，并使计算机变得极其成问题。这很容易。我们知道如何给人们提供计算机访问权限。你如何给他们提供手套，让他们可以安全有效地使用计算机？有时这意味着告诉人们“不”，这正是许多大数据设计问题的本质所在，就像，你如何防止人们，你知道，我想，给他们足够的绳子让他们有用，但又不能多到让他们陷入麻烦。是的，是的，这很有
sense. Yeah, I think that, you know, it you know it's it's yeah i think over time you build this kind of mental model of what kind of works well with what engine um it's like for example like sorting sorting is almost never a good idea in presto because as soon as you want to sort then you never know if as said, a record's going to come that needs to belong in the first position. Like the very last record you look at could actually be the first record when it's sorted. And so the only way to sort is to hold everything in memory, right? So now with Spark, for example, sorting is not an issue because it spills the disk. And so Spark will basically, imagine you have a huge database you want to sort by one column.
道理。是的，我认为，你知道，随着时间的推移，你会建立起一种心理模型，了解什么样的引擎适合什么样的工作。比如，排序在 Presto 中几乎从来都不是一个好主意，因为一旦你想排序，你就永远不知道是否会有一条记录到来，需要排在第一位。你看到的最后一条记录在排序后实际上可能是第一条记录。所以排序的唯一方法是把所有东西都放在内存里，对吧？所以现在以 Spark 为例，排序不是问题，因为它会溢出到磁盘。所以 Spark 会基本上，想象你有一个巨大的数据库，你想按一列排序。
Spark will effectively create a file for, let's say, each letter. So the A file, the B, it's kind of like what you would do if you were sorting a list of folders is you'd have an A group, a B group, a C group, so on and so forth. And then Spark could just sort the A group. And you don't have to do it by the first letter. You could even do it by the first two letters, three letters. And so you could always find a way to do it in Spark where it will be fast and efficient. And yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head that it's very hard to encode that knowledge. It's almost kind of like, you know, you can go to Home Depot and buy a saw. You can't really buy a saw that won't cut your thumb off.
Spark 会有效地为每个字母创建一个文件。比如 A 文件，B 文件，这有点像你整理文件夹列表时会做的事情，你会有一个 A 组，一个 B 组，一个 C 组，以此类推。然后 Spark 只需要对 A 组进行排序。你甚至不需要按第一个字母排序。你甚至可以按前两个字母、三个字母排序。所以你总能在 Spark 中找到一种方法，让它变得快速且高效。是的，我认为你一针见血地指出了，要编码这种知识是非常困难的。这几乎就像，你知道，你可以去家得宝买一把锯子。你买不到一把不会割伤你大拇指的锯子。
They haven't invented that yet and they probably never will. And so it's really about how do you let people experience, you know, materialize or presto or spark in a way where they make mistakes, but they don't kind of blow up the system or cut their thumb off, right? Yep, you're absolutely right. One of the things that's a bit tricky with materialize, I suppose, is that whereas folks have this expectation with a lot of big data tools that you might cut your thumb off or that, you know, you should not randomly do things on your prod cluster, for example. The database community, with their products, have gotten pretty solid about trying to bulletproof a lot of the tools there so that you can't quite as easily
他们还没发明出来，可能永远也不会。所以关键在于如何让人们以一种方式体验 Materialize、Presto 或 Spark，让他们犯错，但不会炸掉系统或割伤自己的大拇指，对吧？是的，你说得完全正确。我认为 Materialize 有一点棘手的地方在于，虽然人们对许多大数据工具有一种期望，即你可能会割伤自己的大拇指，或者你知道，你不应该在生产集群上随意做事情。数据库社区，凭借他们的产品，在尝试对许多工具进行防弹处理方面已经做得相当扎实，这样你就不能那么容易地
catch your system on fire. If some person shows up, if quota's in place, they have ways to protect queries from interfering with each other. So the expectations are a bit higher with that crowd, actually. So this is definitely one of the slightly awkward moments is that the prospects are showing up like, well, I expect to be able to have 20 people use this and not get in each other's way. What's your story?
让你的系统着火。如果有人出现，如果配额到位，他们有办法保护查询不互相干扰。所以实际上，那个群体对期望值更高。所以这绝对是稍微有点尴尬的时刻之一，因为潜在客户出现时会说，好吧，我希望能够让 20 个人使用这个，并且互不干扰。你们的故事是什么？
And we sort of have to come back with, well, our story is big data sort of side of the story, which is that if you really need these people to be isolated from each other, you should probably turn on a few separate copies of Materialize. And it's not as exciting an answer as they're hoping for, for sure. But it's realistic, at least at the moment. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think the way we do it at my company is there's like a Presto quota, probably same thing for Spark. There'sas um and uh and so if you maximize the like in in theory the worst case scenario is where you get as close as possible to once you exceed the quota the job dies so that's actually not that big a deal but it's if you're right at the quota
我们不得不回答说，我们的故事是大数据那一面的故事，也就是说，如果你真的需要这些人彼此隔离，你可能应该开启几个独立的 Materialize 副本。这肯定不是他们希望听到的那种令人兴奋的答案。但至少在目前看来，这是现实的。是的，这很有道理。是的，我认为我在我公司使用的方法是，有一个 Presto 配额，Spark 可能也是一样。所以如果你最大化了，理论上最坏的情况是你尽可能接近配额，一旦超过配额，作业就会死亡，所以这其实没什么大不了的，但如果你一直处于配额边缘
for a really long time and if a bunch of people are doing that, then things can start to get really bogged down. But that should be super, super rare because it's hard to really design something. You can't really optimize your query so that you're just under the quota. Yeah, no, you're totally right. And if people did, there's some clever things. You can totally randomize the quotas a little bit
很长一段时间，如果有一群人都在这样做，那么事情就会开始变得非常缓慢。但这应该是非常非常罕见的，因为很难真正设计出某种东西。你不能真正优化你的查询，使你刚好处于配额之下。是的，你说得完全正确。如果人们真的这样做了，有一些聪明的方法。你可以完全随机化配额
to make sure that... Oh, yeah, just introduce white noise in the quota. Yeah can totally randomize the quotas a little bit to make sure that oh yeah i just introduced white noise in the quote you know harmless just plus or minus a little but enough that no one can actually sniff out where is that that i can safely operate on yeah that's funny um okay cool so so yeah so you kind of actually one thing about materializing we'll go back to the background is it is it ANSI SQL or or have you added things to SQL the target is ANSI SQL um we were very uh very cognizant of the fact that with with SQL the language there's a bit of an uncanny valley where if you are in fact SQL compliant great people can use you tools can use you uh so a lot of people's tooling use SQL if you're only 90% SQL compatible
来确保……哦，是的，只要在配额中引入白噪声。是的，可以完全随机化配额来确保，哦，是的，我只是在配额中引入了白噪声，你知道，无害的，只是加减一点点，但足以让没人能真正嗅探出我在哪里可以安全操作。是的，这很有趣。嗯，好的，酷。所以，关于 Materialize，我们回到背景，它是 ANSI SQL 吗，还是你在 SQL 中添加了东西？目标是 ANSI SQL。我们非常清楚这样一个事实：对于 SQL 这种语言，存在一种“恐怖谷”效应，如果你确实符合 SQL 标准，很好，人们可以使用你，工具可以使用你。所以很多人的工具都使用 SQL。如果你只有 90% 的 SQL 兼容性，
things catch on fire pretty quick you can demo, here's a join and a reduction, oh that's great, join and a reduction pretty happy with that but as soon as people realize that maybe you've got different semantics for nulls in some places or maybe you don't do a great job at multi-way joins
事情很快就会着火。你可以演示，这是一个连接和一个归约，哦，那太棒了，连接和归约，对此很满意。但一旦人们意识到你可能在某些地方对 NULL 有不同的语义，或者你可能在多路连接方面做得不够好，
or support prepared statements or various things like this. Your tools start to fall apart. Things that used to get correct answers suddenly get mysterious glitches in them. And although you thought 90% compatible, the actual usefulness of the SQL is closer to zero at that point. So we've cleaved very strongly to ANSI SQL. SQLite has a 5 million query test battery that we're in total compliance with at the moment. All sorts of really obscene cases, like things that I would never have thought
或者不支持预处理语句或诸如此类的各种事情。你的工具就开始分崩离析了。那些曾经得到正确答案的东西突然出现了神秘的故障。虽然你认为有 90% 的兼容性，但此时 SQL 的实际可用性接近于零。所以我们非常坚定地坚持 ANSI SQL。SQLite 有一个 500 万个查询的测试库，我们目前完全符合。各种非常离谱的情况，比如我永远不会想到
someone would write these queries. You can write correlated subqueries in the join condition of outer join, and it was some pain to get those to be correct, and correct in a streaming fashion. But it makes a lot of sense. It's very sensible to try to do SQL right if you're going to do it. We've not really added too much. There are a few, I would say, interesting interpretations that we've done of things. They're a bit technical.
有人会写出这样的查询。你可以在外连接的连接条件中编写相关子查询，要让这些查询正确，并且以流式方式正确，确实费了一番功夫。但这很有道理。如果你要用 SQL，尝试把它做好是非常明智的。我们并没有真正添加太多东西。我想说，我们对一些事情做了一些有趣的解释。它们有点技术性。
I'm happy to go into them. But there are things that don't really make quite as much sense in a standard database, but have really cool interpretations in the streaming space. Yeah, I mean, what's an example of something that, of one of those things? Yeah, so like one of the things that, so in a standard SQL database, you can use, I'm going to lie a little bit here, but you can use the now function to get the current time for when your query is being run, which I don't know, you might do to print out along with your results, when did a thing actually happen? Well, yeah, something like that. And that's, that's fine. That's a good use of now. You can do something really interesting, though, in materialize, which is to put that now term in a
我很乐意深入探讨它们。但有些事情在标准数据库中并不完全说得通，但在流处理领域却有非常酷的解释。是的，我的意思是，有什么例子是其中之一吗？是的，比如其中一件事，在标准 SQL 数据库中，你可以使用——我这里稍微撒个谎——你可以使用 now 函数来获取查询运行时的当前时间，我不知道，你可能会用它来和你的结果一起打印出来，事情到底是什么时候发生的？嗯，是的，类似的东西。那是很好的 now 的用法。不过，在 Materialize 中，你可以做一些非常有趣的事情，那就是把那个 now 项放在一个
predicate, like in a where clause. So you can say like, where my data dot timestamp greater than now. And what that does is holds back the data until the current time is equal to whatever value is seen in your data. So since we're evolving the results of this query over time, it's going to give essentially a temporal instruction to the system that says, here's an interesting record, don't show it to anyone until the time that is written down in this piece of data. And it allows you to start programming with time and stuff like that in a way that, yeah, you could write that query in vanilla SQL that just does one-off queries and gives you the answer. But it introduces some really interesting new behavior in a streaming system that is going to update the data over time.
谓词中，比如在 where 子句中。所以你可以说，比如，where my data.timestamp > now。它的作用是保持数据，直到当前时间等于你在数据中看到的任何值。因为我们随着时间的推移不断演变这个查询的结果，它实际上会给系统一个时间指令，说，这是一个有趣的记录，在数据中写下的时间之前，不要把它展示给任何人。它允许你开始用时间等东西进行编程，以一种，是的，你可以在普通的 SQL 中编写那个查询，只做一次性查询并给你答案。但在一个会随着时间更新数据的流系统中，它引入了一些非常有趣的新行为。
Yeah, that's wild. I mean, as soon as you introduce something like that, then you can't really throw any data out because you just don't know when it could become relevant, right? Yeah, though, delightfully, right? You can use this exact same query to say, where my data dot timestamp, I think it's less than now. The other direction, the other inequality direction, eventually says like, throw my data away as soon as this time passes, right? Oh, that makes sense. This record will never pass this predicate again, because we know that now only goes up, and you had some piece of data that we've now passed. So this is actually a way to give, in your query, to describe what data are okay to garbage collect and
是的，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，一旦你引入了这样的东西，你就不能真正扔掉任何数据，因为你根本不知道它什么时候会变得相关，对吧？是的，虽然，令人高兴的是，对吧？你可以使用完全相同的查询来说，where my data.timestamp，我想是小于 now。另一个方向，另一个不等式方向，最终说，一旦这个时间过去，就把我的数据扔掉，对吧？哦，这很有道理。这条记录将永远不会再通过这个谓词，因为我们知道 now 只会增加，而你有一些我们现在已经过去的数据。所以这实际上是一种在你的查询中描述哪些数据可以被垃圾回收和
and clean up. So you can keep a, you know, if you wanted to have for example a one hour window that you're maintaining that slides continually through time, you could totally say you know blah blah select all the records where now between mydata.timestamp and mydata.timestamp plus one hour. And that will wait until that time to introduce the data. And one hour later, clean up the record, throw it away. You'll have a constant memory footprint over time. And just stuff like that, that again, if you're thinking about, no, I'm just going to use real data, like a data warehouse.
清理的方法。所以你可以保持一个，你知道，如果你想有一个例如一小时的窗口，你不断地随着时间滑动，你完全可以说，你知道，blah blah，选择所有记录，其中 now 在 mydata.timestamp 和 mydata.timestamp 加一小时之间。它会等到那个时间才引入数据。一小时后，清理记录，扔掉它。你会随着时间的推移保持恒定的内存占用。仅仅是这样的东西，再次，如果你在考虑，不，我只是要使用真实数据，比如数据仓库。
You've got to plop all your data in there. It's got to look at all your data over and over again, because who knows what's going on in there and it's got to look at all your data over and over again because you know who knows what's going on in there by giving clearer instructions to the stream processor we actually can learn a bit more about what do you really need to keep around like what data can we throw away and how can we you know more efficiently operate to keep your query up to date yeah that makes sense so what about you, one of the things that I was really excited to see Spark 3.0 add is the sort of array aggregation and all of that. So like you can, for example, you know, there's an array column type, which is in, you know, in Hive and SQL, but not in ANSI SQL. And that array data type ends up being super, super useful. Like you might say,
你必须把所有数据都扔进去。它必须一遍又一遍地查看你所有的数据，因为谁知道里面发生了什么，它必须一遍又一遍地查看你所有的数据，因为你知道谁知道里面发生了什么。通过给流处理器更清晰的指令，我们实际上可以更多地了解你真正需要保留什么，哪些数据我们可以扔掉，以及我们如何能更有效地操作以保持你的查询处于最新状态。是的，这很有道理。那么，关于你，我非常兴奋地看到 Spark 3.0 添加的东西之一是数组聚合之类的东西。所以，例如，你知道，有一个数组列类型，它在 Hive 和 SQL 中都有，但不在 ANSI SQL 中。而那个数组数据类型最终变得非常非常有用。比如你可能会说，
take all the records with this person's name and build an array of, I don't know, all the ages the person said they were. And then let's analyze that distribution or something. And so that seems to be the thing that I miss the most whenever I'm using something like SQLite. I always kind of miss array ag and map ag and some of these functions. Yeah, we have several of these. I don't want to, I get myself tied up a little bit when I try to distinguish all of them. There's arrays and there are lists and there's a little bit of a difference because Postgres has, we're basically following a lot of Postgres.
获取这个人的名字的所有记录，并建立一个数组，我不知道，这个人说他们所有的年龄。然后让我们分析那个分布之类的。所以这似乎是我在使用像 SQLite 这样的东西时最怀念的东西。我总是有点怀念数组聚合（array ag）和映射聚合（map ag）以及其中一些函数。是的，我们有几个这样的函数。我不想，当我试图区分它们时，我有点把自己绕进去了。有数组，有列表，它们有一点区别，因为 Postgres 有，我们基本上是在跟随很多 Postgres 的做法。
There's some distinctions between the raggedness of arrays versus multidimensional arrays. And it hurts my head to try to keep all of thesegres. There's some distinctions between the raggedness of arrays versus multidimensional arrays. And it hurts my head to try to keep all of these straight. But yeah, I'm thinking of what we have literally at the moment. And we literally have a JSONB aggregation that allows you to do these groupings and then pack them into a common JSON object. If we don't have an array aggregation, it seems like the sort of thing that's super easy to add. But yeah, the functionality, I guess we've generalized it a little bit. I think we've not invented too many things of our own. I want to be careful. But when you look at what folks come to us with, they show up with Avro data. And Avro can represent some quirky things in it. And we got to figure out, someone showed up with some Avro data. We need to make sure that the type system is rich enough
数组的参差不齐与多维数组之间有一些区别。试图把所有这些搞清楚让我的头很痛。但是的，我正在思考我们目前真正拥有的东西。我们确实有一个 JSONB 聚合，允许你进行这些分组，然后将它们打包成一个通用的 JSON 对象。如果我们没有数组聚合，这看起来像是那种超级容易添加的东西。但是的，功能，我想我们已经稍微概括了它。我认为我们没有发明太多我们自己的东西。我想小心一点。但当你看看人们带着什么来找我们时，他们带着 Avro 数据。Avro 可以在其中表示一些古怪的东西。我们必须弄清楚，有人带着一些 Avro 数据来了。我们需要确保类型系统足够丰富，
to reveal the various things that people might've shown up with for data. And that includes various forms of arrays and stuff like that, that aren't as commonly seen in NC SQL. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay, so we got to ETH Zurich. We went back a little bit to talk about NIAID.
以揭示人们可能带来的各种数据。这包括各种形式的数组之类的东西，这些在 ANSI SQL 中并不常见。是的，这很有道理。好的，所以我们到了苏黎世联邦理工学院。我们稍微回过头来谈谈 NIAID。
And so yeah, let's sort of continue the story there. I mean, was Materialize created while you were on this road trip? Or was it like conceptualized while you're on this road trip? So I think the right way to frame it is that Materialize was conceptualized by my co-founder Arjun Narayan, who was working at Cockroach Labs at the time. And he had, during the course of his PhD, been working in the same sort of area, big data systems, stuff like that. Yeah, correct me if I'm wrong, but CockroachDB is like a key value store, right? Like a big data key value store.
所以，是的，让我们继续那里的故事。我的意思是，Materialize 是在你这次公路旅行时创建的吗？还是在你这次公路旅行时构思出来的？所以我认为正确的框架是，Materialize 是由我的联合创始人 Arjun Narayan 构思的，他当时在 Cockroach Labs 工作。他在博士期间一直在这个领域工作，大数据系统，诸如此类的东西。是的，如果我错了请纠正我，CockroachDB 就像一个键值存储，对吧？就像一个大数据键值存储。
Yeah, roughly. I mean, it's more of a transaction processing-y OLTP-style system than an analytic processor. And this makes a bit of sense, to be honest. I would say I'm not an expert here, but they were good at what they were doing, which is storing data, keeping data consistent, all these sorts of things. And we're sniffing around for what's the right way to process all this data. It's sort of silly to do all this and dump it out to HDFS and call into Spark or something like that. And Arjun's take, at least, I hope I'm not misrepresenting him, was that the NIAID paper, the thing that came out of Microsoft Research, was a great answer to
是的，大致如此。我的意思是，它更像是一个事务处理型的 OLTP 风格系统，而不是分析处理器。老实说，这很有道理。我会说我不是这方面的专家，但他们擅长他们正在做的事情，那就是存储数据，保持数据一致性，所有这些事情。而我们正在四处寻找处理所有这些数据的正确方法。做完所有这些，然后把它转储到 HDFS 并调用 Spark 之类的东西，这有点傻。Arjun 的看法，至少，我希望我没有曲解他，是 NIAID 论文，那个来自微软研究院的东西，是一个很好的答案，
all of this. It sort of resolved a lot of the quirks that stream processing systems had at the time, and that this would make a lot of sense for anyone who uses a transaction processor to keep the primary source of truth for their data, but wants to attach to it some analytics that will continually be able to ask questions and also keep answers up to date for questions you've already asked. So I would say he, and potentially collaborators at Cockroach, but he was the one who was pushing forward on the idea that this is really interesting technology. And there's actually a pain point that people have out there where you can use a data warehouse for sure and just ask questions over and over again. But there are a lot of people who have relatively fewer questions, I suppose. They want to see the
解决了所有这些问题。它解决了当时流处理系统所具有的许多怪癖，这对任何使用事务处理器来保持其数据主要事实来源，但又想附加一些分析功能的人来说，非常有意义，这些分析功能将不断能够提出问题，并为已经提出的问题保持答案的最新状态。所以我认为他，以及可能在 Cockroach 的合作者，但他是一个推动这个想法的人，即这确实是一项非常有趣的技术。而且实际上人们确实存在一个痛点，你可以肯定地使用数据仓库，然后一遍又一遍地提出问题。但有很多人，我想，他们的问题相对较少。他们想看到
answers to their queries refreshed as quickly as possible, always up to date. And ideally, this shouldn't have to mean you have to go back to the data warehouse once a second and reissue the query from scratch. So he was the one who showed up, I would say, with the, like, let's actually do something specific here. His pitch to me was roughly like, we, sorry, we knew each other from before, but his pitch with respect to the company was, it's super interesting, like all the stuff and rust that you're building. And you write a bunch of fun blog posts. But if you actually want to see if this has legs, if this can actually go anywhere, there are going to be annoying things that you don't want to have to do.
他们查询的答案尽可能快地刷新，始终保持最新。理想情况下，这不应该意味着你必须每秒回到数据仓库一次，并从头开始重新发出查询。所以他是那个出现的人，我会说，带着，比如，让我们在这里做点具体的事情。他对我的推销大致是，我们，抱歉，我们以前就认识，但他关于公司的推销是，这超级有趣，比如你正在构建的所有 Rust 东西。你写了一堆有趣的博客文章。但如果你真的想看看这是否有潜力，如果这真的能有所作为，会有一些烦人的事情，你不想不得不做。
Someone's got to write documentation. People are going to have to write tests. People are going to have to go and shake hands with potential customers and stuff like that. And that's not what you want to do in your day to day. And you're totally right. But the right vehicle to do this was to put together a company, basically put together something that has some funding so that you can pay people to put together marketing information, to put together documentation websites, write tests, write SQL compatibility layers, stuff like that.
有人必须写文档。人们将不得不写测试。人们将不得不去和潜在客户握手之类的。而那不是你日常想做的事情。你是完全正确的。但做这件事的正确载体是组建一家公司，基本上组建一些有资金的东西，这样你就可以付钱给人们去整理营销信息，去整理文档网站，写测试，写 SQL 兼容层，诸如此类的东西。
Yeah, this touches on a really, really good point. I think there is this kind of misconception that a startup company is, you know, like Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak in their garage, just writing, you're building a bunch of systems, or just, you know, one person in their garage. to have sort of sales. You need to have people writing documentation. You need to have that whole ecosystem right at the beginning. And yeah, I see a lot of people who have some really good technology, but I think they kind of missed that part of it, that you need to have that whole part of it. And we talked a little bit about this in the last episode about Docker. And I don't want to beat up on Docker again, but your Docker has amazing technology. But then on the business side, you know, there were some real challenges. So it's really important to kind of have a person who's really plugged into that, who can help out with all of that. You know, I definitely found this to be the case. I mentioned in most startups, these roles exist, whether you like them or not, of course, you
是的，这触及了一个非常非常好的点。我认为有一种误解，认为初创公司是，你知道，就像史蒂夫·乔布斯和史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克在车库里，只是写代码，你正在构建一堆系统，或者只是，你知道，车库里的一个人。你需要有销售。你需要有人写文档。你需要从一开始就有整个生态系统。是的，我看到很多人有非常好的技术，但我认为他们有点错过了那一部分，你需要有那整个部分。我们在上一集谈到了 Docker，我不想再抨击 Docker 了，但你的 Docker 有惊人的技术。但在商业方面，你知道，确实存在一些真正的挑战。所以有一个真正深入了解这一点的人，能够帮助处理所有这些事情，真的很重要。你知道，我绝对发现情况确实如此。我在大多数初创公司提到过，这些角色存在，无论你喜欢与否，当然，你
know, someone to do community management or tech support or these things. And presumably in most very small startups, everyone just wears five different hats and you probably do a little less good of a job than if you got in a specialist to do a thing. And so part of, I mean, part of what was compelling, I suppose, about Argent's proposal is like, this is good enough stuff that we can get some funding and actually get people who are good at these jobs and like doing them rather than have to slog through the unpleasantness of doing them ourselves necessarily.
知道，有人来做社区管理或技术支持或这些事情。而在大多数非常小的初创公司中，每个人都戴着五顶不同的帽子，你可能做得比雇一个专家来做这件事要差一点。所以，我的意思是，Arjun 的提议中令人信服的一部分是，这是足够好的东西，我们可以获得一些资金，并真正找到那些擅长这些工作并且喜欢做这些工作的人，而不是不得不亲自去做这些令人不快的事情。
Yeah, makes sense. And so did you go straight from ETH to Materialize or was there something in between? Oh, yeah, it, yeah, sorry. There's, there's a bunch of time dilation that went on. Uh, and I was, I was at ETH twice, actually. I was there for seven months the first time and, you know, having, having done the thing that I thought I was there to do, went off and tootled around a bit more, uh, a bit more in Europe. I just happened to be where I was and did some more surfing and just relaxing. Eventually, I ended up going back to ETH for a little over a year and was a bit more
是的，有道理。那么你是直接从 ETH 到 Materialize，还是中间有什么？哦，是的，它，是的，抱歉。有，有，有一段时间的膨胀。呃，我实际上两次在 ETH。第一次我在那里待了七个月，你知道，做完了我认为我在那里要做的事情，就离开了，在欧洲又逛了逛，呃，多逛了一点。我只是碰巧在我所在的地方，又冲浪了一下，放松了一下。最终，我回到 ETH 待了一年多，当时更
formally there at the time. I was working with students, advising folks, sort of helping some folks see through their PhD dissertations. But then it became clear that that was not for me forever and that Material that Materialize made a lot more sense. And the second time there was departed, I would say, early 2019, roughly, and landed in the US. And at that point, Materialize had already been started up, essentially. Arjun and I had chatted about it beforehand and thrown some decks around. But yeah, I came back from Switzerland and was employee, I think, number five,
正式地在那里。我和学生一起工作，为人们提供建议，算是帮助一些人完成他们的博士论文。但后来很明显，那不适合我永远待下去，Materialize 更有意义。第二次离开那里，我想说，是在 2019 年初，大致如此，然后降落在美利坚合众国。那时，Materialize 基本上已经启动了。Arjun 和我之前聊过，并扔了一些演示文稿。但是的，我从瑞士回来，我想我是第五名员工，
I guess, at Materialize at that point. Cool. So what was it like to talk to investors? So I also have an academic background. And since going to university, I've really only worked in research labs. And so you kind of share that background, at least up to ETH. And so what was it like going from that to, you know, creating a pitch deck, talking to investors and, you know, what was that transition like? It was, for me at least, it was very surprising. The thing that's surprising is I think we went through uh about a week of of pitching stuff in in the valley and each meeting that we went into i went in with some
我猜，在 Materialize 那时。酷。那么和投资者交谈是什么感觉？我也有一段学术背景。自从上大学以来，我真的只在研究实验室工作过。所以你们至少在 ETH 之前有那种背景。那么从那到，你知道，创建演示文稿，和投资者交谈，那种转变是什么感觉？对我来说，至少，这非常令人惊讶。令人惊讶的事情是，我想我们经历了一周左右的在硅谷推销东西，我参加的每次会议，我都带着一些
preconceptions and came out with exactly the opposite conclusion basically about what i had expected and like what's an example of that no i mean just like we went in i don't the very first thing we went into we were like oh this is great you know we're pretty solid the the deck looks pretty good. And came out of that, and there was a lot more skepticism about things than we had realized. Not of the type. No one doubted the technology or anything like that. They were less sure about how big the market was, for example.
先入为主的观念，最后得出的结论与我预期的完全相反，基本上是关于我所预期的，比如那是什么例子？不，我的意思是，就像我们进去，我不，我们参加的第一件事，我们就像，哦，这太棒了，你知道，我们相当扎实，演示文稿看起来相当不错。然后从那里出来，对事情的怀疑比我们意识到的要多得多。不是关于类型。没有人怀疑技术或类似的东西。他们不太确定市场有多大，例如。
I didn't even thought of that. Oh, that makes sense. We went into the second meeting, and I was pretty sure that ahead of time, the person that we were going to chat was already invested in and what was essentially a competitor and um we're basically thinking like oh i guess we're we're in deep trouble and like this isn't going to work out we can just sort of warn them and go home and they're immediately like no no i'm interested i'm very interested were you afraid of even giving the pitch you know because because you know, if they're already invested in your competitor?
我甚至没想过那个。哦，这很有道理。我们参加了第二次会议，我相当确定，在之前，我们要聊的那个人已经投资了，本质上是一个竞争对手，嗯，我们基本上在想，哦，我想我们陷入了深渊，这不会成功，我们只能警告他们然后回家，他们立刻说，不，不，我感兴趣，我非常感兴趣。你甚至害怕进行推销吗，你知道，因为因为你知道，如果他们已经投资了你的竞争对手？
Not really. I mean, I think one of the nice things about Materialize that's very reassuring is that nothing we're doing is secret. So it's not that there's some cunning information that if anyone got access to it, they would suddenly have a big advantage over us. The main advantage that we have is the technology that we're using is pretty cutting edge, I would say. I mean, that's self-serving, but that's the main thing that distinguishes us. And it's not trivial for anyone else to say, oh, I see. We should just use the same technology and we'll be where they are. So we weren't too worried.
并不是真的。我的意思是，我认为 Materialize 的好处之一是非常令人放心的，那就是我们所做的一切都不是秘密。所以并不是说有什么狡猾的信息，如果任何人获得了访问权限，他们就会突然比我们有很大的优势。我们拥有的主要优势是我们正在使用的技术相当尖端，我会说。我的意思是，那是自私的，但那是区分我们的主要东西。而且任何人说，哦，我明白了，我们应该使用相同的技术，我们就会达到他们所在的位置，这并不简单。所以我们并不太担心。
At least I wasn't too worried about showing up and saying, hey, we're going to do a thing. This is the thing we're going to do. Keep it a secret. I don't think anything that we were talking about was particularly secretive. So no, I wasn't too worried about that. Maybe I should have been. I don't know. I'm hopelessly naive when it comes to some of these things. No. I mean, I think what you said really resonates. I mean, I think to replicate it, they have to really replicate your whole history um it's not good enough just to take take a snapshot of of um you know what you're thinking
至少我不担心出现并说，嘿，我们要去做一件事。这就是我们要做的。保密。我不认为我们谈论的任何事情特别隐秘。所以不，我并不太担心那个。也许我应该担心。我不知道。当涉及到其中一些事情时，我无可救药地天真。不。我的意思是，我认为你所说的真的引起了共鸣。我的意思是，我认为要复制它，他们必须真正复制你的整个历史，嗯，仅仅拍一张你正在思考的快照是不够的，
right now you have to it's not markovian right like it's it's kind of based on your trajectory is kind of based on your all of your experiences and you can't easily transfer that that's totally true so for example one of the things that things that we've had to do and has been some of the value that's been added and materialized is trying to figure out how to take a bunch of these crazy SQL idioms and map them down to dataflow computation. So when someone has a correlated subquery, someone's got to figure out how to turn that into dataflow computation. And that's not explained anywhere else. That's not a thing that exists in the open source software that I had previously written. So it was very much on that like the team will be able to figure this
现在你必须，它不是马尔可夫的，对吧？就像它，它有点基于你的轨迹，有点基于你所有的经历，你不能轻易地转移它。这是完全正确的。所以，例如，我们必须做的事情之一，也是 Materialize 增加的一些价值，是试图弄清楚如何获取一堆这些疯狂的 SQL 习语并将它们映射到数据流计算。所以当有人有相关子查询时，有人必须弄清楚如何将其转化为数据流计算。这在其他任何地方都没有解释过。这不是我之前编写的开源软件中存在的东西。所以这非常取决于团队将能够弄清楚这一点，
out was was the bet that the vcs were making not that the software already does it but that there will be some some problems they'll be faced but these people are well prepared to get out clear those hurdles essentially that makes sense and so this this investor was super interested and then did did you kind of uh what was that conversation like? At some point, you had to kind of talk about the elephant in the room, right? Which the people they're invested in but they also have responsibility to the people who've invested in their in their funds and as long as they're not in conflict i think this person's particular take was like as long as it's not zero sum right if it's if all the money that you would make would come at the expense of these other people uh that's no good that that's not a thing that they can yeah but if investing in two people who happen to be sharing a pie in the course of that, the pie is actually, let's say, 50% bigger than it initially was, then, you know, okay, company one doesn't get all the money in the world. Companies one and two have to share it. But it's, it's, in this case, much better for their, the investors in the fund that the vc is managing i i have to imagine also that there's different takes on this right across the the spectrum of vcs you know some people are
这是风险投资家们下的赌注，不是软件已经做到了，而是他们会面临一些问题，但这些人准备充分，可以清除这些障碍，本质上。这很有道理。所以这个投资者超级感兴趣，然后你，那种对话是什么样的？在某个时候，你必须谈论房间里的大象，对吧？也就是他们投资的人，但他们也对投资他们基金的人负责，只要他们没有冲突，我想这个人的特别看法是，只要它不是零和博弈，对吧？如果所有你赚的钱都是以牺牲其他人为代价的，那就不好了，那不是他们可以，是的，但如果投资两个碰巧在过程中分享一块馅饼的人，馅饼实际上，比最初大了 50%，那么，你知道，好吧，公司一没有得到世界上所有的钱。公司一和公司二必须分享它。但它，在这种情况下，对他们的，风险投资家管理的基金的投资者来说，要好得多。我必须想象，在风险投资家的范围内，对此也有不同的看法，你知道，有些人
perhaps a bit more kind and gentle maybe and some people are more vicious and and uh you know trying to get access to whatever money is that they can get i have i have no idea i definitely don't want to want to judge there. Yeah, totally. This is just one meeting. But I think it's really an interesting kind of dichotomy because on one side, yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head. It really depends on is the pie growing. So if there's 1,000 customers and the startups are only able to sort of acquire one at a time, and you know that there's a whole ecosystem full of startups, um, you know, when companies get so
也许更友善和温柔，有些人更恶毒，你知道，试图获得他们能得到的任何钱。我，我不知道，我绝对不想评判。是的，完全正确。这只是一个会议。但我认为这确实是一个非常有趣的二分法，因为一方面，是的，我认为你一针见血。这真的取决于馅饼是否在增长。所以如果有 1,000 个客户，而初创公司只能一次获得一个，而且你知道有一个充满初创公司的生态系统，嗯，你知道，当公司变得如此
big that they basically exhaust the market and then they go to war with each other. Um, and, and, uh, it's, it's a fascinating podcast, but, but yeah, I think that is maybe, you know, if you're, if you're, uh, if materialize is like competing with, you know, the next biggest player, uh, you know, and both companies are, you companies are dominating the world together, then that's not a bad position to be in if you're an investor. It's like, okay, I'll take that. Yeah, no, you're not wrong.
大以至于他们基本上耗尽了市场，然后他们就互相开战了。嗯，而且，这是一个迷人的播客，但，但是的，我认为这也许是，你知道，如果你，如果你，呃，如果 Materialize 正在与，你知道，下一个最大的参与者竞争，你知道，而且两家公司正在一起统治世界，那么如果你是投资者，那不是一个坏的位置。就像，好吧，我会接受那个。是的，不，你没错。
And each of the participants, Materialize and the other person, would really love if the other person would sort of not be there. Their lives would be a lot easier. But from the investor's point of view, presumably, no, this is great. Like both of you are going to make better products.
而且每个参与者，Materialize 和另一个人，如果对方不在那里，他们会非常高兴。他们的生活会容易得多。但从投资者的角度来看，大概，不，这太棒了。就像你们两个都会做出更好的产品。
You know, both of you are going to compete to be price competitive. I'm sorry, I'm making up a bunch of economic stuff. I have no actual background here, but I can imagine a world where it's not inappropriate to support folks who are, yeah, again, eating more of the pie as opposed to trying to fight over the same piece of pie. Yeah, yeah, totally.
你知道，你们两个都会竞争以具有价格竞争力。抱歉，我编造了一堆经济学的东西。我这里没有任何实际背景，但我可以想象一个世界，支持那些，是的，再次，吃掉更多馅饼而不是试图争夺同一块馅饼的人，并不是不合适的。是的，是的，完全正确。
So, okay, you start up Materialize, you're employee number five, and you have this sort of academic background. I'm assuming there are a mixture of people who are really into the theory and handling a lot of these edge cases and doing a lot of these really complex transformation of SQL to your engine. And then there are a lot of, I guess, front-end engineers, and there's a whole engineering area. How do those two areas kind of collaborate? It's a great question. I think the short version is that the folks who are really interested in the theory, like the me type people, needed to adapt a little bit. And this is mostly because when you look at it, what Materialize actually needs to do, the goal isn't specifically to advance some very cunning theory and to be really smart and write obnoxious blog posts. It's actually to do a specific thing. And if you look
好的，你加入了 Materialize，是第五名员工，而且你有学术背景。我假设团队里既有热衷于理论、处理各种边缘情况、将 SQL 进行复杂转换到引擎的人，也有很多前端工程师，还有整个工程部门。这两个领域是如何协作的？这是一个很好的问题。简短的回答是，那些对理论非常感兴趣的人，比如像我这样的人，需要做出一些调整。这主要是因为当你审视 Materialize 真正需要做的事情时，目标并不是专门去推进某种深奥的理论，也不是为了显得聪明而去写那些令人讨厌的博客文章。它实际上是为了完成一件具体的事情。如果你看看
at if the folks, generally speaking, the engineering side of the house at Materialize is a bit more eyes on the prize about like, we need to actually make this work. That's the actual goal. The goal is, okay, the friends are made along the way. That's also very good. But the reason that we're here is to try to put together a thing that looks and behaves a lot like,
如果说，总的来说，Materialize 的工程部门更关注目标，即我们必须真正让它运行起来。这才是真正的目标。目标是，好吧，沿途结交的朋友也很棒。但我们在这里的原因是试图构建一个看起来和行为上都很像的东西，
in this case, Postgres complies with SQL and under the covers does it all very efficiently, hopefully, things like that. And that's actually the goal. So folks should, in some sense, to get in. And that's actually the goal. So, you know, folks should, in some sense, to get in line and do that, that sort of work. And I remember when I showed up, I was very initially very like, Oh, this is exhausting. SQL has so many, so many warts. It's just, it's gross in a few different ways. Do we have to do this? And, you know,
在这种情况下，Postgres 兼容 SQL，并且在底层非常高效地完成所有工作，希望如此，诸如此类。这才是真正的目标。所以人们在某种意义上应该加入进来。这才是真正的目标。所以，你知道，人们在某种意义上应该排好队，去做那种工作。我记得我刚来的时候，最初觉得这太累人了。SQL 有太多的缺陷。它在很多方面都很糟糕。我们非得这么做吗？而且，你知道，
at the time, maybe, I was thinking, maybe we don't, you thinking maybe we could do some funny business somewhere. And the answer is pretty clear. No, no. It's really important to do SQL correctly. That may suck. I'm sorry. But the thing that we're making makes sense if we do SQL correctly and not otherwise. So let's figure out how to do that.
当时，也许我在想，也许我们不需要这样做，你可能在想我们能不能在某些地方搞点花样。答案很明确。不，不。正确地实现 SQL 非常重要。这可能很糟糕。我很抱歉。但我们正在制造的东西只有在正确实现 SQL 的情况下才有意义，否则就没有意义。所以让我们弄清楚如何做到这一点。
Yeah. I mean, speaking from the other side of the table, there is something that wasn't ANSI SQL. I'm trying to remember. I think it was maybe like Hive. Yeah, Hive. So Hive isn't ANSI SQL. And so just converting queries from Presto to Hive or from testing them locally on SQLite and converting them to Hive, it's never a straight conversion. It's always a huge pain. And you're always kind of wondering like, why didn't they just take the extra step? Now, I mean, Hive, I think that whole Hadoop ecosystem was filling such a huge void that they had a lot of latitude in terms of the product. But ultimately, I mean, Hive was replaced by Presto and Spark and things that were
是的。我是说，站在桌子的另一边，有些东西不是 ANSI SQL。我试着回忆一下。我想可能是像 Hive 这样的东西。是的，Hive。所以 Hive 不是 ANSI SQL。因此，仅仅是将查询从 Presto 转换到 Hive，或者在本地 SQLite 上测试它们然后转换到 Hive，从来都不是直接的转换。这总是一件非常痛苦的事情。你总是会想，为什么他们不直接多走一步呢？现在，我是说，Hive，我认为整个 Hadoop 生态系统填补了一个巨大的空白，以至于他们在产品方面有很大的回旋余地。但最终，我是说，Hive 被 Presto 和 Spark 以及其他一些东西所取代，这些东西
more compliant. So, I mean, even then, I mean, it didn't last, it was just a honeymoon phase. Right. But yeah, you hit the nail on the head. I mean, if it, if, if, you know, especially if you're at a bigger company, if you have, you know, 20,000 queries that you run and you push them to materialize and like a hundred of them fail, you know, for one person who's trying out a new product, that's insurmountable to try to fix 100. It's usually really ugly fixes 100 times. And so it kind of can't be 99% done. It has to be 100% for you to really get those customers.
更合规。所以，即使那样，它也没有持续下去，那只是蜜月期。没错。但你说得对。我是说，如果，如果，你知道，特别是如果你在一家大公司，如果你有 20,000 个查询要运行，然后你把它们推送到 Materialize，结果有 100 个失败了，你知道，对于一个试图尝试新产品的人来说，要修复这 100 个问题是不可逾越的。通常修复 100 次是非常丑陋的。所以它不能只完成 99%。它必须是 100%，你才能真正获得那些客户。
Yeah, that's absolutely correct. And again, one of the changes, I guess, coming from the academic space is like in the academic world, it's a bit introspective there. You're like, my goal is to think of a clever thing and then tell the world about it. Whereas in the business, the real world side of the things, your goal is to meet the potential users where they are. You want to get some technology to them that they can pick up immediately and start working with. And they're more and more delighted the less they have to screw around with it or figure out. Or if their life is now fixing these 100 queries as people write new ones, that's terrible. I mean, that's not the thing that they were hoping it was going to be. You get to notice this a bit more as you show up. I was learning this, at least, coming from academia, where you get rewarded for being clever and different.
是的，这绝对正确。再说一次，我认为从学术界来到这里的一个变化是，在学术界，它有点内省。你会想，我的目标是想出一个聪明的东西，然后告诉全世界。而在商业、现实世界中，你的目标是满足潜在用户。你想给他们提供一种技术，让他们可以立即上手并开始工作。他们越不需要折腾或研究，就越感到高兴。或者，如果他们的生活现在变成了在人们编写新查询时修复这 100 个查询，那太糟糕了。我是说，那不是他们希望它成为的样子。当你出现时，你会更多地注意到这一点。至少，我从学术界来到这里时正在学习这一点，在学术界，你因为聪明和与众不同而获得奖励。
To a space where absolutely the goal is to try to be as not different as possible ideally not have to tell anyone about your cleverness they just sort of experience that your product is for whatever reason much more pleasant to use than the competition yeah that makes sense and so in terms of customer acquisition is is your is your is materialize the style kind of like a bottom-up thing where you have a free tier and you try and get developers to convince their manager or director to jump on board? Or is it more of like an enterprise thing where you go and make a pitch to the leadership? What's the kind of model for Materialize? It's a good question.
到一个目标绝对是尽量不要与众不同的空间，理想情况下是不必告诉任何人你的聪明才智，他们只是体验到你的产品因为某种原因比竞争对手更令人愉快。是的，这很有道理。那么在客户获取方面，Materialize 的风格是自下而上的吗？比如你有一个免费层级，试图让开发人员说服他们的经理或主管加入？还是更像是一种企业模式，你去向领导层推销？Materialize 的模式是什么样的？这是一个好问题。
I probably just screwed up the answer to this because there are very clear takes on each of these things. My experience with Materialize has been that the people that we end up trying to convince Materialize is good have so far been not strictly the bottom-up, just random developer trying to get a thing done, but maybe a tier up from that. So a person who's trying to think about,
我可能把这个问题的答案搞砸了，因为对这些事情中的每一项都有非常明确的看法。我在 Materialize 的经验是，我们最终试图说服 Materialize 很好的人，到目前为止，并不是严格意义上的自下而上，不是随便一个试图完成某项工作的开发人员，而是比那高一个层级的人。所以是一个试图思考的人，
how should I organize infrastructure for my group or something like that? Or I need to support a few people, various people writing SQL queries. How should I go about doing that? And this person has some latitude to make a good decision or bad decision. But they're a decision making type of person rather than a person who can pull whatever they want onto their laptop
我应该如何为我的团队组织基础设施，或者类似的事情？或者我需要支持一些人，各种编写 SQL 查询的人。我该怎么做？这个人有权做出好的决定或坏的决定。但他们是决策型的人，而不是那种可以把任何他们想要的东西拉到笔记本电脑上的人
and start using it. At the same time, we're not sort of going over and scheduling meetings with Coca-Cola to try to tell them like, you know, please, please stop using big competition and start using us instead, you know, business, business, business, handshakes, martinis. I would say the motion is a bit more bottom-up in the sense that it's technology-led. Folks are meant to understand, the users are meant to understand that this is a valuable thing to do,
然后开始使用它。与此同时，我们并没有去和可口可乐安排会议，试图告诉他们，你知道，请停止使用大竞争对手，转而使用我们，你知道，商业，商业，商业，握手，马提尼。我会说这种动作更偏向自下而上，因为它是技术驱动的。人们应该理解，用户应该理解这是一件有价值的事情，
that they like the experience more, low-latency responses to queries are better, as opposed to more top-down, like your organization will be better, cheaper, whatever, if you pivot over to materialize. That might also be true, but it's harder to put that in front of people at the moment. Yeah, I think anything having to do with, you know, data, you know, anything having to do with data will require you to be a step up from the developer because it's not something you can run on the cloud. Like people aren't going to just move all their data
他们更喜欢这种体验，低延迟的查询响应更好，而不是更自上而下的，比如如果你转向 Materialize，你的组织会变得更好、更便宜等等。这可能也是真的，但目前很难把它放在人们面前。是的，我认为任何与数据有关的事情，你知道，任何与数据有关的事情都需要你比开发人员高出一个层级，因为它不是你可以在云端运行的东西。就像人们不会只是把他们所有的数据
to some kind of public cloud that Materialize has access to. And so something has to be, I'm assuming something has to be kind of done where Materialize is kind of plugged into whatever, you know, their data system. I mean, it might be on AWS, but it's obviously not going to be something that's exposed to the public.
移动到某种 Materialize 可以访问的公共云。所以必须做点什么，我假设必须做点什么，让 Materialize 接入他们的任何数据系统。我是说，它可能在 AWS 上，但显然不会是暴露给公众的东西。
Yeah. Oh, I should say, to take this opportunity to throw out there, that Materialize Cloud has just entered private beta. Folks, go to materialize.com slash cloud and hop onto the sign-up list. Folks are being admitted in waves, but
是的。哦，我应该说，借此机会抛出一点，Materialize Cloud 刚刚进入私有测试阶段。各位，去 materialize.com/cloud 并加入注册列表。人们正在分批被录取，但是
the intent is for sure to try to put together a thing where an organization can try this out. We'll deploy inside your private cloud in AWS. But if you've got your data in Kafka or something like that, we can attach a materialized instance to it and start reading it and give you 30 seconds or something like that. An interactive experience where you get to see what it's like to start using this. Maybe start to make some decisions about, are you loving this or is it the same problems as before? Yeah, that makes sense. But insofar as like, it is kind of a bigger commitment than trying out a different ID, for example. And so insofar as that's true, like I would say from what you described, Materialize is sort of bottom up
意图肯定是试图构建一个组织可以尝试的东西。我们将在你的 AWS 私有云中部署。但如果你的数据在 Kafka 或类似的东西中，我们可以将一个 Materialize 实例连接到它，开始读取它，并给你 30 秒左右的时间。一种交互式体验，让你看看开始使用它是什么感觉。也许开始做出一些决定，你是喜欢它，还是它和以前一样有问题？是的，这很有道理。但就它比尝试不同的 IDE 等等更大的承诺而言。所以就这一点而言，我会说根据你所描述的，Materialize 在某种程度上是自下而上的
at the lowest level that you you can reach and still get the kind of commitment that you need to set up it's you're right that it's more sophisticated than just getting a new a new id or a new a new theme for vs code or something like this for sure we've tried to make it not terrible from the point of view of an incremental deployment so for for example you know step one is not reformat all of your data into our native representation or something like that. We'll look at your Kafka topics, pull data out of there that could be CSV formatted, could be Avro or JSON, various things.
在你所能达到的最低水平，并且仍然能得到你所需要的承诺来设置它。你是对的，它比仅仅获得一个新的 IDE 或一个新的 VS Code 主题等等要复杂得多。当然，我们试图从增量部署的角度让它不那么糟糕。所以，例如，第一步不是将你所有的数据重新格式化为我们的原生表示等等。我们会查看你的 Kafka 主题，从那里提取数据，可能是 CSV 格式，可能是 Avro 或 JSON，各种东西。
Hopefully the ways you've already written your data down so that we're not actually introducing any new costs for you. So it's not as bad, for sure, other systems out there systems out there step one is okay we need to pivot all of your data and hdfs into a columnar representation because that's the only way we work efficiently so like one week later you can actually try running one of these yeah yeah exactly uh sort of grindy uh olappy style uh analytics tools that makes sense so you're kind of plugged into um kafka and i think the amazon is like i want to say it's kinesis this is another one that they have yeah yeah yeah there's a bunch
希望是你已经编写数据的方式，这样我们实际上不会为你引入任何新的成本。所以它肯定没有那么糟糕，其他系统第一步是好的，我们需要将你 HDFS 中的所有数据透视成列式表示，因为那是我们高效工作的唯一方式，所以一周后你才能真正尝试运行其中一个，是的，是的，完全正确，呃，那种繁琐的 OLAP 风格的分析工具，这很有道理。所以你有点接入了 Kafka，我想亚马逊的那个我想说是 Kinesis，这是他们有的另一个，是的，是的，有一堆
of these um pub sub type things or you know basically sources we'll say sources for real-time data and so you've written kind of adapters for a lot of these different sources and so as long as people are using one of these, you know, kind of standard things, then they can, they can try out materialize. Yeah. And the goal for sure is to show up from our part, show up with as many of these points of integration as we can reasonably manage with, with the team that we have. So, you know, if you can pull data Kafka is the easy one at the moment,
这些发布订阅类型的东西，或者你知道，基本上是源，我们称之为实时数据的源。所以你已经为很多这些不同的源编写了适配器，只要人们在使用这些标准的东西之一，那么他们就可以尝试 Materialize。是的。我们的目标肯定是展示出来，尽我们所能与我们拥有的团队一起管理尽可能多的这些集成点。所以，你知道，如果你能提取数据，Kafka 目前是最简单的，
Kinesis has some interesting characteristics that make it a bit harder to show people the data and be correct and show them the same data again the second time if it crashes and starts up again. But for example, also there's some recent work to pull data out of Postgres as a read replica, essentially. So to use the replication protocol out of just a Postgres instance and say, if you have your data in Postgres, materialize can attach to that. Oh, that makes sense. Yeah. So stepping back a bit, looking at someone who's in high school or college and maybe they have some very, very limited SQL, like maybe they've written, they've made some MySQL queries on a startup, a small project, a hobby project. How can they get started with Materialize?
Kinesis 有一些有趣的特性，使得向人们展示数据并保持正确，以及在它崩溃并重新启动时再次向他们展示相同的数据变得有点困难。但例如，最近还有一些工作是从 Postgres 中提取数据作为只读副本，本质上。所以使用 Postgres 实例的复制协议，并说，如果你的数据在 Postgres 中，Materialize 可以连接到它。哦，这很有道理。是的。那么退后一步，看看一个高中生或大学生，也许他们有一些非常非常有限的 SQL 知识，比如也许他们在初创公司、小项目、爱好项目中编写过一些 MySQL 查询。他们如何开始使用 Materialize？
And is there sort of a free tier? Or what's a way for students and hobbyists to learn more? Oh, absolutely. I mean, you can definitely... Materialize is source available and very nearly as available as we can make it. It's BSL licensed. So basically anyone can go and grab it.
有没有免费层级？或者学生和业余爱好者了解更多的方法是什么？哦，绝对有。我是说，你绝对可以……Materialize 是源码可用的，而且尽可能地可用。它是 BSL 许可的。所以基本上任何人都可以去获取它。
And as long as you aren't building a competing database as a service style product, you're free to use it for whatever you want. And you can go grab the code, build it. We have Docker images that we should push out each time we successfully build something. And you can just grab this down, pull it down to your laptop. You don't need any complicated Apache infrastructure. You don't need ZooKeeper up and running, any of that stuff. It's literally a single binary. You turn it on, you connect to it as if it were Postgres. So if you have a terminal and you use P-SQL, which is a standard way to shell into Postgres, you can use that to connect and materialize. And if you don't have Kafka up and running, you can point it at a file, for example, and you can append rows of, let's say,
只要你不是在构建一个竞争性的数据库即服务产品，你就可以随意使用它。你可以去获取代码，构建它。我们有 Docker 镜像，我们应该在每次成功构建某些东西时推送出来。你可以直接获取这个，拉到你的笔记本电脑上。你不需要任何复杂的 Apache 基础设施，你不需要 ZooKeeper 运行，任何那些东西。它实际上是一个单一的二进制文件。你打开它，像连接 Postgres 一样连接到它。所以如果你有一个终端，并且你使用 P-SQL，这是 shell 进入 Postgres 的标准方式，你可以用它来连接 Materialize。如果你没有运行 Kafka，你可以把它指向一个文件，例如，你可以追加行，比如说，
text, a bunch of different formats, but append rows of text to the file and see the results continue to update there. This is one of the sorts of interop that, it's a little janky, but this is how folks have prototypes on things. You have a file on your laptop that's continually scraping some other source of data on the internet, appending stuff to the file, and then materializes essentially tailing that file. It's watching for changes to it, and anytime new data show up, it'll push them into the pipeline
文本，各种不同的格式，但追加文本行，并看到结果在那里持续更新。这是那种互操作性之一，它有点简陋，但这就是人们在某些事情上进行原型设计的方式。你的笔记本电脑上有一个文件，它在持续抓取互联网上的其他数据源，将东西追加到文件中，然后 Materialize 本质上是在跟踪那个文件。它在监视它的变化，任何时候有新数据出现，它都会把它们推送到管道中
and update all of your queries. And you can do all of this without a complicated enterprise infrastructure or anything. It's just on your laptop. This is how I use Materialize a lot, to be totally honest. Oh, that makes sense. You could use it as kind of like a tail on steroids. No, absolutely. If you're used to using, I don't know, like awk or something like that to do a little bit of data munging through your CSVs and needed something more advanced than
并更新你所有的查询。你可以在没有复杂的企业基础设施或任何东西的情况下完成所有这些。它就在你的笔记本电脑上。老实说，这就是我经常使用 Materialize 的方式。哦，这很有道理。你可以把它当作一种增强版的 tail。不，绝对是。如果你习惯使用，我不知道，比如 awk 或类似的东西来通过你的 CSV 进行一点数据处理，并且需要比
that, like awk is great at what it does. I use awk a lot, but if you're like, geez, I really need to take these five CSVs and find things present in here and not present in there, get the distinct these things back out, yada, yada, yada, something sql like um yeah you totally use material let's do that and and keep things up to date as data change if that's if that's exciting to you that is really really cool yeah that is that's really let me just give a bit of tech background and feel free to kind of correct any any records here because this is uh this is just shooting from the hip here. So a bit of background. So in Unix, there's tail. So you can have a big text file. You do tail file. You get the last 10 lines, right? Simple enough. There's also tail-f. If you do tail-f, instead of just giving you the
那个更高级的东西，比如 awk 在它擅长的事情上很棒。我经常使用 awk，但如果你想，天哪，我真的需要获取这五个 CSV，找出这里存在而那里不存在的东西，把这些不同的东西取回来，等等等等，类似 SQL 的东西，嗯，是的，你完全可以使用 Materialize 来做那个，并在数据变化时保持更新，如果这让你感到兴奋的话。这真的很酷。是的，那真的很酷。让我稍微介绍一下技术背景，如果有什么记录不对，请随时纠正，因为这只是即兴发挥。所以一点背景。在 Unix 中，有 tail。所以你可以有一个大的文本文件。你执行 tail file。你得到最后 10 行，对吧？很简单。还有 tail-f。如果你执行 tail-f，它不会只是给你
last 10 lines, it will actually just listen to that file just forever. And anytime a line is added, appended to that file, Tail will print it out. So think of Tail-F as like this monitor that's just listening for changes and writing them out. There's also a bunch of other Unix commands, like there's awk and there's sed and there's jq. All of these are ways of extracting data so if you if your if your file is rows of json objects so every line in your file is a json object you could you could pipe that over to jq and you could pull out one of the entries one of the keys in that object right if your file is just is rows of text and maybe there's a timestamp you're interested in, you can use tr and set and awk,
最后 10 行，它实际上会永远监听那个文件。任何时候有一行被添加、追加到那个文件中，Tail 就会把它打印出来。所以把 Tail-F 想象成一个监听变化并把它们写出来的监视器。还有一堆其他的 Unix 命令，比如 awk、sed 和 jq。所有这些都是提取数据的方法，所以如果你的文件是 JSON 对象行，那么你文件中的每一行都是一个 JSON 对象，你可以把那个管道传给 jq，你可以提取其中一个条目，对象中的一个键，对吧？如果你的文件只是文本行，也许有一个你感兴趣的时间戳，你可以使用 tr、sed 和 awk，
these other tools to pull out that timestamp. But then, as soon as things start to get complicated, like maybe you need to keep a rolling histogram or something like that, you're really kind of stuck. I mean, at that point, I mean, you could try doing something with Python. You know, at that point, you're basically writing a Python program that reads from standard in. And as soon as you jump into Python, you're writing a lot of code and et cetera, et cetera.
这些其他工具来提取那个时间戳。但是，一旦事情开始变得复杂，比如你可能需要保持一个滚动直方图之类的东西，你就真的被卡住了。我是说，在那一点上，我是说，你可以尝试用 Python 做点什么。你知道，在那一点上，你基本上是在编写一个从标准输入读取的 Python 程序。一旦你跳进 Python，你就在编写大量的代码，等等等等。
So SQL would be really attractive. There's a lot of times where I've converted things to, or just loaded things into a SQLite database just so I can run queries. And it takes a long time. You have to transform the data, especially if it's just flat text. And so Materialize, running it locally is a really, really attractive alternative. You could have a Materialize that's tailing CSV or I think it's called JSONL, where there's a JSON object per line, a JSONL format, and do more complicated things like groups and windows and all of that, without having to, you know, that sounds absolutely correct. I realized I say tail a lot. And we say tail outside materialize, but tail dash F is actually you're right, absolutely the exact
所以 SQL 会非常有吸引力。有很多次我把东西转换成，或者只是加载到 SQLite 数据库中，这样我就可以运行查询。这需要很长时间。你必须转换数据，特别是如果它只是纯文本。所以 Materialize，在本地运行它是一个非常非常有吸引力的替代方案。你可以有一个正在跟踪 CSV 的 Materialize，或者我想它叫 JSONL，每行有一个 JSON 对象，一种 JSONL 格式，并做更复杂的事情，比如分组、窗口等等，而不必，你知道，这听起来绝对正确。我意识到我经常说 tail。我们在 Materialize 之外说 tail，但 tail-f 实际上你是对的，绝对是确切的
specific use of tail that we should be thinking of. Yeah, I mean, there's tail the verb, and then there's tail the command, right? I think tail the command is just as one-shot thing. But I think you're totally right. One of the things we've seen a lot of interest from folks about are not even necessarily big data, anything in particular. Those folks are interested, of course, but there are other folks who are just putting together, let's just call them web apps or something like that. I suppose at the moment they would be using something like Firebase to get told about changes to their data, but in fairly primitive, elemental
我们应该考虑的 tail 的特定用法。是的，我是说，有动词 tail，还有命令 tail，对吧？我认为命令 tail 只是那种一次性的东西。但我认为你是完全正确的。我们看到人们对此有很多兴趣的事情之一甚至不一定是大数据，任何特别的东西。那些人当然感兴趣，但还有其他人只是在组装，我们称之为 Web 应用或类似的东西。我想目前他们会使用像 Firebase 这样的东西来获知他们数据的变化，但以相当原始、基础的
ways. Maybe they pass a filter and you get to see records that pass the filter. That might then prompt them to redraw a web page or do some work like that. Materialize is pretty appealing and you get to have the same experience except you push a more interesting query through to the server, essentially. You could say, this is wonderful, but just only show me when a particular,
方式。也许他们通过一个过滤器，你就能看到通过过滤器的记录。这可能会促使他们重新绘制网页或做一些类似的工作。Materialize 相当有吸引力，你可以获得相同的体验，除了你本质上向服务器推送了一个更有趣的查询。你可以说，这太棒了，但只在我看到一个特定的、
more complicated property happens. Show me when new distinct users show up or someone logs in after five minutes later than they had ever previously logged in, things like this. These people don't necessarily have terabytes of data to work on, but it's really handy to have someone save them the pain of writing the Python or the JavaScript or whatever it is that is handwritten bespoke code to try to put together a thing that does the not necessarily very complicated task of figuring out when should i tell someone that a new thing has happened and materialize is well sort of popular in that space at least as as an idea like why can't we
更复杂的属性发生时才显示给我。当新的不同用户出现时显示给我，或者有人在比他们之前登录时间晚五分钟后登录时，诸如此类的事情。这些人不一定有 TB 级的数据要处理，但有人能帮他们省去编写 Python 或 JavaScript 或任何手写定制代码的痛苦，试图构建一个能完成 figuring out 何时应该告诉某人新事情已经发生这一不一定非常复杂的任务的东西，这真的很方便，而且 Materialize 在那个领域相当受欢迎，至少作为一个想法，为什么我们不能
have this for other classes of programming essentially sql and big data is is great but there's lots of other people who deal with reactive applications, essentially. They're trying to build whatever, literally React-style webpages that you want to express what it should look like, the data might change, why can't the computer system take care of all this for me? So the bug, I think, is getting out there in terms of people expecting, even wanting, but eventually expecting that their system can actually take care of all of these updates for them. They don't have to handwrite a whole bunch of triggers and weird callbacks and stuff
为其他类别的编程拥有这个，本质上。SQL 和大数据很棒，但还有很多其他人处理反应式应用，本质上。他们试图构建任何东西，字面上的 React 风格的网页，你想表达它应该看起来像什么，数据可能会改变，为什么计算机系统不能为我处理所有这些？所以我认为这个 bug 正在传播，人们期望，甚至想要，但最终期望他们的系统实际上可以为他们处理所有这些更新。他们不必手写一大堆触发器和奇怪的回调等等
like that. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. I think one of the biggest challenges or biggest mistakes that people make when they're starting out is um is is using is using a programming language or maybe in other words saying is using something like python or c++ instead of using you know unix commands and and sql um i think that uh you know i know when i was when i was going to college um you know i I kind of thought, oh, well, SQL, that's for, you know, that's for, you know, people with real jobs, you know, like I'm a PhD student. So if I needed to, you know, read one column out of a CSV, I would just start, you know, into main and writing C++. And that made me extremely unproductive. And I think that it's a lesson
那样。是的，这很有道理。我认为人们在刚开始时犯的最大挑战或最大错误是使用编程语言，或者换句话说，是使用像 Python 或 C++ 这样的东西，而不是使用 Unix 命令和 SQL。我认为，你知道，我知道当我上大学时，你知道，我有点认为，哦，好吧，SQL，那是给，你知道，那是给，你知道，有真正工作的人用的，你知道，比如我是博士生。所以如果我需要，你知道，从 CSV 中读取一列，我只会开始，你知道，进入 main 并编写 C++。这让我极其没有效率。我认为这是一个
that's super, super important. And having the ability to do a real time, yeah, I think there's a massive, massive tail of folks who can make really, really good use of something like that, that just don't know about it. There's there's a computer science principle actually that gives name to this, this thing called Oosterhout's dichotomy, where this is, I think John Oosterhout at Stanford who proposed essentially this, roughly two types of programming languages, right? There's sort of this productivity level language. That's a bit like, I don't know, awk would be a good example or SQL. You know, you can use it to get your job done as quickly as possible.
超级超级重要的教训。并且有能力进行实时，是的，我认为有大量大量的人可以很好地利用这样的东西，只是不知道它。实际上有一个计算机科学原理给这个东西命名，叫做 Oosterhout 二分法，这是，我想是斯坦福大学的 John Oosterhout 提出的，本质上是这个，大致有两种类型的编程语言，对吧？有一种生产力水平的语言。这有点像，我不知道，awk 会是一个很好的例子，或者 SQL。你知道，你可以用它来尽可能快地完成你的工作。
And then there's more systems-y programming languages. Let's call them C++ or something, which is, let's say you want to build one of these tools. Someone actually has to build the things. And if you know one of each of these languages, that's pretty good. Only knowing a productivity language or a systems language, you're going to have some limitations, either because you only know C++ and you spend all of your days trying to open files and read lines and stuff like that. Or if you only
然后还有更偏向系统的编程语言。我们称之为 C++ 或类似的东西，也就是，假设你想构建这些工具之一。必须有人真正构建这些东西。如果你知道这些语言中的每一种，那相当不错。只知道一种生产力语言或一种系统语言，你会有一些限制，要么是因为你只知道 C++，你整天都在试图打开文件和读取行等等。或者如果你只
know SQL, it's a little hard to invent a new thing, essentially. If SQL isn't doing what you want, you're kind of in trouble at that point and need to get someone else to help you. But if you know one of each of these things and can move between them, that's a really good place to be.
知道 SQL，发明新东西有点难，本质上。如果 SQL 没有做你想要的，在那一点上你就有麻烦了，需要找别人帮你。但如果你知道这些东西中的每一种，并且可以在它们之间移动，那是一个非常好的位置。
Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Cool. Yeah, I think this is amazing. So folks out there, we should definitely, I'll give it a shot. I think folks out there should definitely grab Materialize. So I know there's Docker. Docker is usually pretty heavyweight, but are there just standalone, statically compiled binaries for different OSes? Yeah, hopefully I'm not screwing this up, but I think we have them. We have like an app get repo.
是的，这很有道理。酷。是的，我认为这太棒了。所以外面的朋友，我们绝对应该，我会试一试。我认为外面的朋友绝对应该获取 Materialize。所以我知道有 Docker。Docker 通常很重，但有没有针对不同操作系统的独立、静态编译的二进制文件？是的，希望我没有搞砸，但我认为我们有。我们有像 apt get repo。
There's, I believe we have it at times. I should make sure it's up to date, but homebrew versions of these things, you know, you just grab the code and build it from source if you're that sort of person. I should double check all of the package managers we have, though. I think there's a few that we for sure keep up to date and some that we might have uh either let slip or lost some traction with yeah i mean someone who has i have a package in a bunch of these package managers and it's it's so difficult i mean i'm currently right now i have i have an issue on ubuntu 18 but it works on all the other ubuntus and 10 different other OSs.
有，我相信我们有时有。我应该确保它是最新的，但这些东西的 homebrew 版本，你知道，如果你是那种人，你直接获取代码并从源码构建它。不过我应该仔细检查我们拥有的所有包管理器。我想有几个我们肯定保持更新，有些我们可能要么让它溜走，要么失去了一些吸引力。是的，我是说，有人在这些包管理器中有一个包，这太难了，我是说，我目前现在在 Ubuntu 18 上有一个问题，但它在所有其他 Ubuntu 和 10 个其他操作系统上都能工作。
And so it just never ends. There's always something that breaks somewhere. It's a real job keeping that up to date. I think one of these days, someone needs to write some way to automate that. But that's going to be a challenge because they're all so different. I mean, I'm sure someone has written that thing,
所以它永远不会结束。总是有什么东西在某处坏掉。保持更新是一项真正的工作。我想总有一天，有人需要编写某种自动化方法。但这将是一个挑战，因为它们都太不同了。我是说，我相信有人已经写了那个东西，
but it's only supported on some of the OSs, so you can only use it in some stuff. I mean, it's one of these, like the XKCD cartoon about there are 14 competing standards. We should invent a new one that encapsulates all of them. Now there's 15. Now there's 15. Yeah, it's so true.
但它只在某些操作系统上受支持，所以你只能在某些东西中使用它。我是说，它是这些之一，就像关于有 14 个竞争标准的 XKCD 卡通。我们应该发明一个新的来封装它们所有。现在有 15 个了。现在有 15 个了。是的，太真实了。
Yeah, I guess that thing is probably Snapcraft, which doesn't have enough market penetration. Like, I don't think they cover Windows. And so, yeah, you're right, you can't really, I mean, maybe you could lower your number of things, but you can't get it down to one. cool so let's let's jump into into materialize as as a company um so what is a day like for a scientist or an engineer and materialize like how you know specifically like how is it everyone kind of or i guess pre-covid let's say everyone drove into work you know had a cubicle or has a bullpen but is there something kind of unique about life at Material Life? Well, we're in New York City, so no one drove anywhere. You would hop into your metal cylinder and be propelled from one end of the city to the other. I mean, it's changed. I guess it's part of the problem. So I'm trying to get a snappy way to characterize it. But early days, it was, you know, we're all basically in
是的，我想那个东西可能是 Snapcraft，它没有足够的市场渗透率。就像，我不认为他们覆盖 Windows。所以，是的，你是对的，你不能真的，我是说，也许你可以减少你的东西数量，但你不能把它降到一个。酷，所以让我们跳进 Materialize 作为一家公司，那么科学家或工程师在 Materialize 的一天是什么样的，比如你怎么，你知道具体来说，每个人是怎么，或者我假设在新冠之前，假设每个人都开车去上班，你知道，有一个隔间或有一个大办公室，但 Materialize 的生活有什么独特之处吗？好吧，我们在纽约市，所以没有人开车去任何地方。你会跳进你的金属圆筒，被从城市的一端推进到另一端。我是说，它变了。我想这是问题的一部分。所以我试图找一种时髦的方式来描述它。但早期，它是，你知道，我们基本上都在
within 10 feet of each other. And there's a bunch of rapid prototyping and sort of turnover where like, I'd put together some code and then hand it over to someone else. And they'd come back and say, like, this doesn't, you know, this isn't correct from Seek. Okay, well, let's iterate on it. There was a lot of dynamic energy where things were randomly changing and we were trying stuff out. As we've gotten bigger, this has cooled down a little bit in that people go crazy if you just randomly change what they're working on while they're working on it.
彼此 10 英尺内。并且有一堆快速原型设计和某种周转，比如，我会整理一些代码，然后交给别人。他们会回来并说，这不，你知道，这从 Seek 来看是不正确的。好吧，让我们迭代它。有一种动态能量，事情在随机变化，我们正在尝试各种东西。随着我们变大，这稍微冷却了一点，因为如果你在人们工作时随机改变他们正在做的事情，他们会发疯。
So we have, I mean, sorry, this is not unique to Materialize, but a process now of sort of goal setting and stuff like that, trying to figure out, for example, in turning on the Cloud product, what are the steps we still need to do before we're comfortable putting that in front of people? Folks have nicely carved up bits of work where we're pretty comfortable. I mean, if the work gets done, it
所以我们有，我是说，抱歉，这并不是 Materialize 独有的，但现在有一个目标设定等等的过程，试图弄清楚，例如，在开启云产品时，在我们舒适地把它放在人们面前之前，我们还需要做哪些步骤？人们已经很好地划分了工作，我们很舒服。我是说，如果工作完成了，它
doesn't necessarily matter how it gets done. You don't need to be butt in the seat for any particular hours of the day or anything like that. Depends a little. The cadence changes a little bit. Sometimes something new and exciting gets put out there, and it's worth having you sit around for a little while to see, did anything catch on fire,
不一定在乎它是怎么完成的。你不需要在一天中的任何特定时间坐在座位上，或者类似的事情。稍微有点依赖。节奏稍微改变了一点。有时一些新的和令人兴奋的东西被发布出来，值得让你坐一会儿看看，有没有什么东西着火了，
help out people who don't understand exactly what you did but but generally speaking what's the coolest uh off-site that you folks have done well so we haven't we haven't done two we've we've got a few and i'll name my favorite one but uh we haven't done too many because uh it's just about a year um and then uh and then covid happens oh yeah that's right it's not too much not any off-site since then we desperately want to do one but we've done we've done, we've done two basically. We went to upstate New York and did some hiking. This is when we were about five or six people. And I don't know, you know,
帮助那些不完全理解你做了什么的人，但总的来说，你们做过的最酷的 off-site 是什么？好吧，我们没有做过两个，我们有几个，我会说出我最喜欢的一个，但我们没有做太多，因为这大约一年，然后新冠发生了。哦，是的，那是对的，从那以后没有太多 off-site。我们非常想做一个，但我们做过，我们做过两个，基本上。我们去了纽约州北部，做了一些徒步旅行。这是在我们大约五六个人的时候。而且我不知道，你知道，
I would say fairly stereotypical, but super fun. You know, like hiking during the day and then, then smash brothers at night and you know, some new calling and some whiskey and stuff like that. But this, it was totally appropriate for, for who we were and what we wanted to do at the time. Some folks went rock climbing.
我会说相当刻板，但超级有趣。你知道，比如白天徒步旅行，然后晚上 smash brothers，你知道，一些新的调用和一些威士忌等等。但这，对于我们当时是谁以及我们想做什么来说，是完全合适的。有些人去攀岩了。
Everyone was just happy to get out of the city and just sort of stretch their legs in the outdoors. And that was great. And then come, I think it was February, actually, before anything got especially weird, we actually went on essentially a skiing trip. It was up in Vermont and it was raining rather than snowing and you know it was just mostly getting some time out of the standard work environment where you still get to be social with your colleagues you get to
每个人都很高兴离开城市，只是在户外伸展一下腿。那太棒了。然后来，我想是二月，实际上，在任何事情变得特别奇怪之前，我们实际上去了一个本质上的滑雪旅行。它在佛蒙特州，下着雨而不是雪，你知道，这主要是为了从标准工作环境中获得一些时间，在那里你仍然可以与同事社交，你得到
you know it reinforces the fact that these are actual humans not just people who write annoying comments on your on your pr or something like that and just chill with chill with people spend some time socializing that uh doesn't have to be in a bar drinking or something like that. It can just be pretty mellow, taking walks or just over dinner. Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, I think with COVID it's a challenge. I mean, most of our, I guess, quote-unquote off-sites have been just playing video games.
你知道，它强化了这样一个事实，即这些是真正的人类，而不仅仅是在你的 PR 上写烦人评论的人，或者类似的事情，只是和人们放松，花一些时间社交，那不需要在酒吧喝酒或类似的事情。它可以很温和，散步或只是在晚餐时。是的，那太棒了。是的，我认为有了新冠，这是一个挑战。我是说，我们的大多数，我假设，所谓的 off-site 只是玩电子游戏。
We just take some time out and play some games together, play a bit of Counter-Strike or something it's a little complicated because during covid i would love to do this i have like a virtual offsite though it feels like a very weird thing to require of people like it's it's one thing to say like we're all getting in a car and we're going somewhere awesome which basically like okay fair enough um but if you tell them like we're all taking next week and we're not going anywhere interesting but you got to log on and play some video games or something like that and And a lot of the folks, I'd rather do something else,
我们只是花点时间一起玩一些游戏，玩一点 Counter-Strike 或类似的东西，这有点复杂，因为在新冠期间，我很想这样做，我有一个虚拟的 off-site，尽管这感觉像是对人们要求非常奇怪的事情，就像说我们都要上车，我们要去某个很棒的地方，这基本上就像，好吧，公平地说，但如果你告诉他们，我们都要占用下周，我们不去任何有趣的地方，但你必须登录并玩一些电子游戏或类似的东西，而且很多人，我宁愿做点别的，
to be totally honest. And it's hard to, I mean, on the one hand, you'd love to, you know, take some time off of work to get people a bit more social interactive, but it's a bit hard to tell them like,
老实说。而且很难，我是说，一方面，你很想，你知道，从工作中抽出一些时间让人们更社交互动，但很难告诉他们，
you know, your time, which is scarce at this moment, needs to be spent screwing around with us, playing Scattergories online or something like that. Yeah, it is. It is super awkward. I think it's a real challenge. And yeah, it's a fine line you have to walk between. If you make it kind of, let's say, if you don't hype it up and promote it, then people won't show up. But then then if you make it mandatory then it kind of feels like you're in the show the office right yeah so so there's some fine line there so we had we had a holiday party for example which uh was done virtually and you know straddle
你知道，你现在稀缺的时间，需要花在和我们一起折腾，在线玩 Scattergories 或类似的事情上。是的，它是。它超级尴尬。我认为这是一个真正的挑战。而且，是的，你必须在之间走一条细线。如果你把它弄得，让我们说，如果你不炒作和推广它，那么人们就不会出现。但如果你把它变成强制性的，那么它感觉就像你在看办公室一样，是的，所以那里有一条细线，所以我们有一个节日派对，例如，它是虚拟完成的，你知道，跨越
this line pretty pretty well i guess like you know we it wasn't strictly speaking mandatory but everyone was definitely encouraged to come and and folks leaned into that and you know got dressed up and made their own fairly nice dinners and showed them off on zoom and stuff like this. And this felt pretty good. Like it felt good that it wasn't, you know, and now mandatory sit and look in a camera and have dinner together, which is not nearly as exciting as we're all going to go out and have some, some cocktails and then a nice dinner.
这条线相当不错，我想，就像你知道，它不是严格意义上的强制性的，但每个人都绝对被鼓励来，人们倾向于那样，你知道，打扮起来，做了他们自己相当不错的晚餐，并在 Zoom 上展示它们等等。这感觉相当不错。感觉很好，它不是，你知道，现在强制坐着看摄像头并一起吃晚餐，这远没有我们都要出去喝点鸡尾酒然后吃顿美餐那么令人兴奋。
Yeah. One thing I, my team hasn't done this, but another team, I think it was like HelloFresh. Yeah, there's this thing called HelloFresh where they'll deliver ingredients to cook a meal and it's just enough ingredients to make a very specific meal. And so they delivered this to everyone's house on the same day.
是的。有一件事，我的团队没有这样做，但另一个团队，我想是像 HelloFresh。是的，有一个叫 HelloFresh 的东西，他们会运送食材来做一顿饭，而且食材刚好够做一顿非常具体的饭。所以他们同一天把这个送到每个人的家里。
And then everyone set up know set up uh uh their portal device or their phone on a stand or something like that and we all i mean they all just kind of cooked together i thought that was really clever i like the idea a lot though i got to say like the same sort of problems creep up especially uh you know folks in new york who you know some folks that are at least you know kitchens are not not the centerpiece of the apartment and if you tell them like unfortunately you're gonna have to cook your own dinner tonight um you know no ordering yeah it's in the interest of the company that that you cook your own dinner and eat what you make uh almost sounds like punishment i think it's really fun i like
然后每个人都设置了，你知道，设置了他们的门户设备或他们的手机在支架上或类似的东西，我们都，我是说，他们都只是在一起做饭，我觉得这真的很聪明，我非常喜欢这个想法，尽管我不得不说，同样的问题会悄悄出现，特别是，你知道，在纽约的人，你知道，有些人至少，你知道，厨房不是公寓的中心，如果你告诉他们，不幸的是，你今晚必须自己做晚餐，你知道，没有订购，是的，为了公司的利益，你做你自己的晚餐并吃你做的东西，听起来几乎像惩罚，我觉得这真的很有趣，我喜欢
cooking you know i never i never thought about that yeah i mean i also really love cooking because it kind of shows how uh you know we all kind of like bring our own biases right like i never would have thought that but when you put it in that perspective it totally makes sense right i bet there's some people who uh were just like like what you know what i don't you know like my kitchen is just like this stack of of uh of boxes yeah i mean same thing our first offsite was this hiking stuff in upstate new york and i could i loved it i think that's i love being out in the woods and running around and stuff like that. But I could totally imagine there's some other folks who are like, why is this is not what I thought of when I thought it was fun.
烹饪，你知道吗，我从来没想过这一点。是的，我的意思是，我也非常喜欢烹饪，因为它在某种程度上展示了我们每个人是如何带着自己的偏见去处理事情的。我从来没想过这一点，但当你从那个角度来看时，它完全说得通。我敢打赌有些人会觉得，这算什么？我的厨房里只是一堆盒子。是的，同样的事情，我们的第一次团建是在纽约州北部的徒步旅行，我非常喜欢。我喜欢待在树林里，到处跑之类的。但我完全可以想象，有些人会觉得，这和我所认为的乐趣完全不同。
I was thinking we're going to sit in a chair and drink some beer or something. And it's a different structure for folks, I suppose. But like this, I suppose, again, this is one of these things that there's an art to doing it. And it's not necessarily a thing that's super easy to fake. So I'm impressed when people do it well of how do we bring together a bunch of people who have you know different different goals different ideas of fun and nonetheless get them to connect yeah when you can do that that's great yeah that makes sense so are you folks uh hiring like either interns or full-time or oh totally yeah yeah no everyone
我以为我们会坐在椅子上喝啤酒什么的。我想这对大家来说是一种不同的结构。但就像这样，我想这又是一件需要艺术才能做好的事情。而且这不一定是一件很容易伪装的事情。所以我很佩服那些能把这件事做好的人，他们是如何把一群有着不同目标、不同乐趣想法的人聚集在一起，并让他们建立联系的。是的，如果你能做到这一点，那就太棒了。这很有道理。那么你们是在招聘实习生还是全职员工？哦，完全是，是的，每个人
anyone who's interested should reach out. I think generally the answer is yes. If you have a particular affinity for this sort of thing, we're interested for sure in interns all across, I think all across the spectrum of engineering background. I don't think any particular thing where we said, no, no, we just need to stop hiring this that or the other thing that makes sense and so post-covid the office is in new york city and so so people should uh uh you know if people are interested that's one of the things they should expect that that they would uh head over we have we have actually several
任何感兴趣的人都应该联系我们。我认为总的来说答案是肯定的。如果你对这类事情有特别的兴趣，我们肯定对工程背景各个领域的实习生都很感兴趣。我不认为有什么特别的事情是我们说不，我们不需要再招聘这个那个了。这很有道理。所以疫情之后，办公室在纽约市，所以如果人们感兴趣，这是他们应该预料到的事情，他们会前往那里。我们实际上有几个
locations now and we have we have people sorry several locations is too strong we've hired remote people who are not going to be moving to new york you know folks are in california folks are in europe stuff like that so that's definitely on the table i think you know we're excited by all of this there's a management overhead associated with it so so the engineering management for example for sure has the ability to say like no like we don't know how to handle someone in this time zone um and i don't want to wake up at two in the morning to do their, their one-on-ones.
地点了，我们有，抱歉，说有几个地点太夸张了。我们雇佣了不会搬到纽约的远程员工，比如在加州的人，在欧洲的人等等。所以这绝对是可以考虑的。我认为我们对所有这些都感到兴奋。这确实伴随着管理开销，例如工程管理部门肯定有权说，不，我们不知道如何处理处于这个时区的人，我不想在凌晨两点起床去和他们进行一对一谈话。
So there's a bit of a pushback if they're not in an existing time zone that we have, we'll need to figure out how to manage that growth. But I think if, if you're interested and excited about this sort of thing, I think reaching out is a hundred percent the right thing to do. And we can try to figure out, you know, if not now, when, or, or see what makes sense. Cool. And so for folks who are figure out, you know, if not now, when, or see what makes sense. Cool. And so for folks who are interested in, you know, grabbing a copy of Materialize, trying
所以如果他们不在我们现有的时区，会有一些阻力，我们需要弄清楚如何管理这种增长。但我认为如果你对这类事情感兴趣并感到兴奋，我认为联系我们绝对是正确的做法。我们可以试着弄清楚，如果不是现在，那是什么时候，或者看看什么才是合理的。酷。那么对于那些想弄清楚，如果不是现在，那是什么时候，或者看看什么才是合理的。酷。那么对于那些对获取一份Materialize副本并尝试
it out, like we said, it's super, super accessible. You can get it from, you know, an app repo or brew or whatever. But definitely check out the website first and learn about it. You can go to materialize.com. It's materialized with a Z. So I think that's the American version. I think materialized with a z so i think i think that's the american version i think materialized with an s is the british version that's right and something like the main interesting point i guess is that there's if you go to materialize with an s there's a
它的人来说，就像我们说的，它非常非常容易上手。你可以从应用仓库或brew之类的渠道获取它。但一定要先查看网站并了解它。你可以访问materialize.com。它是带Z的materialized。所以我认为那是美国版本。我认为带Z的materialized，所以我认为那是美国版本，我认为带S的materialized是英国版本。没错，我想主要有趣的一点是，如果你访问带S的materialize，那里有一个
company there they're a different company um and you might have a very different experience if you apply for an internship uh there you might yeah that's right So they're actually a fish farm. I have no idea. But yeah, Materialize with a Z. And, you know, you can, I'm sure there's a careers page, you could check all of that out. There's a place where you can try out materializing and uh actually so one day just to be clear you can like run materialize over a file right i mean if you're totally totally yeah text files um like a csv is a classic thing that you can um we have we have a few worked examples on the web page and one of them literally as long as you have an internet connection uh just starts w getting data from uh from wikipedia about what are people editing, for example, at the moment. Just starts pulling that down to your computer and has a built-in query that asks who are the top contributors as this data set evolves. And it's just grabbing the data continually once you start the little tasklet.
公司，他们是另一家公司。如果你在那里申请实习，你可能会有非常不同的体验。是的，没错。他们实际上是一家养鱼场。我不知道。但是的，带Z的Materialize。而且我相信有一个职业页面，你可以查看所有这些信息。有一个地方可以让你尝试Materialize。实际上，为了清楚起见，你可以像在文件上运行Materialize一样，对吧？我的意思是，如果你完全，完全是的，文本文件，比如CSV是一个经典的东西，你可以……我们在网页上有几个工作示例，其中一个只要你有互联网连接，就会自动从维基百科获取关于人们正在编辑什么的数据。它只是开始将其下载到你的计算机上，并有一个内置查询，询问随着数据集的发展，谁是顶级贡献者。一旦你启动那个小任务，它就会持续抓取数据。
And there wasn't necessarily any data in your computer beforehand, but there is now. And you're just sort of looking at that as it evolves. You could do some other crazy stuff with that, too, and play with it. Yeah. Cool. It makes sense. And so if people want to talk to you about Materialize, they can also at you at Frank McSherry on Twitter. Absolutely. And we'll post all of that in the show notes.
而且你的计算机上之前不一定有任何数据，但现在有了。你只是在它演变时观察它。你也可以用它做一些其他疯狂的事情，并玩玩它。是的，酷。这很有道理。所以如果人们想和你谈论Materialize，他们也可以在Twitter上@FrankMcSherry。当然。我们会在节目笔记中发布所有这些信息。
Yeah, no, for sure. We're definitely active on Twitter. I mean, a thing that I didn't mention, I suppose, is that if you're going to materialize, there's also, for example, a bunch of blog posts, stuff that we've written, just I would say slightly more conversational content about what's interesting or different going on in here. And it's a great place to look to sort of form some questions, for example, like this looks great.
是的，当然。我们绝对活跃在Twitter上。我的意思是，我没提到的一件事是，如果你要使用Materialize，还有很多博客文章，我们写的东西，我会说更具对话性的内容，关于这里正在发生什么有趣或不同的事情。这是一个很好的地方，可以用来形成一些问题，例如，这看起来很棒。
But and then reaching out in person is totally fine. Like that's I spend a bunch of my time trying to help people work people through like what's different here, or I don't see how you can do that or whatnot. And it's a great thing to do in public. Bunch of people learn from it who didn't necessarily know to ask or couldn't figure out how to frame their questions. Yeah, that makes sense. I think, you know, another thing is, is for folks out there who are trying to get into
但随后亲自联系也是完全可以的。我花了很多时间帮助人们解决这里有什么不同，或者我不明白你怎么能那样做之类的问题。这在公开场合做是一件很棒的事情。很多人从中学习，他们不一定知道要问什么，或者不知道如何组织他们的问题。是的，这很有道理。我想，你知道，另一件事是，对于那些试图进入
maybe like, you know, uh, database engineering, you know, the best thing to do is to get your feet wet, you know, using some of these tools. And at some point you might kind of be scratching your head saying, you know, I don't really know how to do this in materialize and I don't really know how to do it any other way either. You know, maybe I'll write a plugin or maybe I'll fork it and make some changes. And the next thing you know, Frank comes knocking on your door saying,
也许是数据库工程领域的人来说，最好的办法就是通过使用这些工具来积累经验。在某个时候，你可能会挠头说，我真的不知道如何在Materialize中做到这一点，我也不知道用其他任何方式怎么做。也许我会写一个插件，或者也许我会分叉它并做一些修改。然后下一件事就是Frank敲你的门说，
hey, this is some pretty cool stuff. Why don't you come work at Materialize? So, I mean, you jump into these projects and dive in. And the source, it's totally open source. So it's an amazing way to kind of learn. And it sounds like it's a very powerful tool for just about anybody. I would definitely say Materialize, I was supposed to say more than other things, but maybe that's not fair. But Materialize has this cool property so far that you can do some pretty interesting things with it, some unexpected things, stuff we hadn't planned for, for sure.
嘿，这东西很酷。你为什么不来Materialize工作呢？所以，我的意思是，你跳进这些项目中去深入研究。而且源代码是完全开源的。所以这是一种学习的绝佳方式。听起来它对任何人来说都是一个非常强大的工具。我绝对会说Materialize，我本应该说比其他东西更多，但这可能不公平。但Materialize到目前为止有一个很酷的特性，你可以用它做一些非常有趣的事情，一些意想不到的事情，一些我们肯定没有计划过的事情。
So I think maybe, well, as much as other projects out there, getting your feet wet and starting to use it often leads to something surprisingly cool and interesting. And I don't know, maybe Jeral is interested in it, but even just your friends are posting on Hacker News or something. There's some cool things that you can do with Materialize that many of us didn't expect ahead of time and didn't know. Like, oh, well, I didn't realize this was the main problem in sports statistics or something. It's something we don't know anything about. And you're like, yeah, I just put. And now it does a thing. And everyone's super stoked. You can build some pretty cool and new different things. And telling people about those is wonderful as well. But I think you're right, just to sort of loop back around a thing
所以我认为也许，嗯，和其他项目一样，积累经验并开始使用它通常会导致一些令人惊讶的酷和有趣的事情。我不知道，也许Jeral对它感兴趣，但即使只是你的朋友在Hacker News上发帖之类的。你可以用Materialize做一些很酷的事情，我们很多人事先都没有预料到，也不知道。比如，哦，我没意识到这是体育统计中的主要问题之类的。这是我们一无所知的事情。你会说，是的，我只是放进去。现在它做了一件事。每个人都超级兴奋。你可以构建一些非常酷和新的不同东西。告诉人们这些事情也很棒。但我认为你是对的，只是为了回到那个
that getting your feet wet, whether it's with materialize or other data platforms, is a great way to start getting a handle on like what's hard what's easy what do you find to be most most unpleasant a lot of the folks the engineers who aren't materialized are there because i literally just asked some folks recently they're there because this was painful in their previous lives and if they can make this better they find that really exciting but getting that context for like what's hard hard, what's easy, what would I like to make better is invaluable. That makes sense. And so for people who have never worked with SQL before, what do you recommend to them? Does Materialize link to some like kind of generic SQL tutorials or is there your favorite tutorial that you point people to?
积累经验，无论是使用Materialize还是其他数据平台，都是开始掌握什么是难的、什么是容易的、你觉得最不愉快的是什么的好方法。很多不在Materialize的工程师在那里是因为我最近确实问了一些人，他们在那是因为这在他们以前的生活中很痛苦，如果他们能让这变得更好，他们会觉得这非常令人兴奋。但获得关于什么是难的、什么是容易的、我想要改进什么的背景信息是无价的。这很有道理。那么对于那些以前从未使用过SQL的人，你向他们推荐什么？Materialize是否链接到一些通用的SQL教程，或者是否有你向人们推荐的最喜欢的教程？
I don't think we do link to a generic SQL tutorial. That's a really interesting point. Actually, we have documentation on the SQL that we support. So as if Materialize had invented SQL, of course, that's not the case, but that's the way the docs are sort of structured. It's a really good question, actually. I came to SQL in a very non-standard roundabout way, having done a whole bunch of data parallel computation first and then looped back around and tried to map SQL onto it. So I wouldn't recommend that path. I liked it a lot, but it took many years. I'm not really sure. There's a bunch of, I think, for example, Marcus Weinand has a fairly well-regarded
我不认为我们链接到通用的SQL教程。这是一个非常有趣的点。实际上，我们有关于我们支持的SQL的文档。就好像Materialize发明了SQL一样，当然事实并非如此，但文档就是这样组织的。这确实是一个很好的问题。我以一种非常非标准、迂回的方式接触SQL，先做了大量的数据并行计算，然后绕回来试图将SQL映射到它上面。所以我不会推荐那条路。我很喜欢它，但花了很多年。我不太确定。我认为，例如，Marcus Weinand有一个评价相当高的
introduction to SQL and also skilling up SQL stuff. I don't know the webpage off the top of my head, but I could try to track that down. I have to imagine there's good and bad SQL tutorials, yeah. Yeah, I mean, we can add anything to the show notes. I'll track it down and I'll hand it out and we can make sure it's linked. Yeah, I also, like you, I kind of learned SQL through, yeah, I was basically at a place where a bunch of the code was written in SQL.
SQL入门以及提升SQL技能的内容。我记不清那个网页了，但我可以试着找出来。我不得不想象有好的和坏的SQL教程，是的。是的，我的意思是，我们可以把任何东西添加到节目笔记中。我会找出来并分发，我们可以确保它被链接。是的，我也像你一样，我通过，是的，我基本上在一个很多代码都是用SQL编写的地方学习SQL。
And so that was kind of my way of getting thrown into it. And then I kind of realized post hoc, like, oh, I should have learned this a decade ago. And so, yeah, I actually, I'm pretty sure we've done a show on SQL. It might be dated now, although the standard doesn't change very often. So it's still relevant. But in that episode, I'll see if I can link to that one as well. We'll have a bunch of references.
所以那是我被投入其中的方式。然后我事后意识到，哦，我应该十年前就学这个。所以，是的，我实际上很确定我们做过一期关于SQL的节目。现在可能过时了，尽管标准不会经常改变。所以它仍然相关。但在那一集中，我会看看是否也能链接到那一集。我们会有一堆参考资料。
So yeah, definitely check out, learn SQL, I guess that's step one. Really, really important, super useful. SQLite is very, very accessible. Materialize is very, very accessible and they will make your life so much easier. And then after you learn SQL, check out Materialize and very, very accessible and they will make your life so much easier. And then after you learn SQL, check out Materialize and start using it.
所以是的，一定要去看看，学习SQL，我想那是第一步。真的非常重要，超级有用。SQLite非常非常容易上手。Materialize非常非常容易上手，它们会让你的生活变得轻松得多。然后在你学习SQL之后，看看Materialize并开始使用它。
So yeah, I think we can kind of put a bookmark here, but Frank, that was a really, really amazing inspiring talk. I mean, I feel like I wanna try, I'm gonna go and grab Materialize right now and I have some files that I want to see kind of how it works on them. And I think the idea of having kind of a SQL query that works on streaming and running that same one on batch and not having to write two of everything, you know, all of that is
所以是的，我想我们可以在这里做一个书签，但Frank，那真是一个非常非常令人惊叹、鼓舞人心的谈话。我的意思是，我觉得我想尝试一下，我现在就要去获取Materialize，我有一些文件，我想看看它在上面是如何工作的。而且我认为拥有一个可以在流式处理上工作的SQL查询，并在批处理上运行同一个查询，而不必为每件事写两遍，你知道，所有这些都是
super, super appealing. I think people out there have learned a lot in the past hour. And so I really appreciate your time and you coming on the show. It's not a problem at all. I'm happy to be here. And actually, the questions are great and really sort of draw out for me at least what's exciting and sort of stimulating what we're doing, why we're doing it. And hopefully, you know, the listeners, some fraction of them agree and like, yeah, that does sound like a thing that I either need or really want or something like that. That sort of then resonates with us for building it.
超级超级吸引人的。我认为人们在过去的一个小时里学到了很多。所以我真的很感谢你的时间和你来到节目中。这根本不是问题。我很高兴来到这里。实际上，这些问题很好，至少对我来说，确实引出了什么是令人兴奋的，以及是什么在刺激我们正在做的事情，为什么我们要这样做。希望，你知道，听众中有一部分人同意并觉得，是的，这听起来确实是我需要或非常想要的东西之类的。这随后与我们构建它的初衷产生了共鸣。
Yeah, totally. Thanks again. You know, for folks out there, we're working on doing two shows a month. So you might be surprised to see this show considering we, we already have an April show.
是的，完全正确。再次感谢。你知道，对于听众朋友们，我们正在努力每月做两期节目。所以你可能会对看到这期节目感到惊讶，考虑到我们已经有了一期四月的节目。
So you might be surprised when you're seeing another April show. And so that's, that's what's going on there. We're going to, we've been working with some really, really nice folks who have been helping us with a lot of the post-processing and that's allowed us to ultimately produce more content, which is super exciting. And the reason why we can do that is because of your ongoing support. So thank you so much, folks out there who are subscribed on Patreon and people who found out about Audible through the show, through our shows.
所以当你看到另一期四月节目时，你可能会感到惊讶。这就是正在发生的事情。我们一直在与一些非常非常好的伙伴合作，他们一直在帮助我们进行大量的后期处理，这使我们最终能够制作更多的内容，这非常令人兴奋。我们之所以能做到这一点，是因为你们的持续支持。所以非常感谢你们，在Patreon上订阅的朋友们，以及通过节目发现Audible的朋友们。
So thank you all so much for all of your support, your emails. We get a whole bunch of new ideas over the past few weeks that we've added to our list. So the content is still growing faster than we can consume it, which is really, really important and great.
所以非常感谢你们所有的支持，你们的电子邮件。在过去的几周里，我们收到了很多新的想法，并将它们添加到了我们的列表中。所以内容增长的速度仍然超过了我们消化的速度，这真的非常非常重要和棒。
And everyone have a great rest of the month and we'll see you all next time. Music by Eric Farndeller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
祝大家这个月剩下的时间过得愉快，我们下次再见。音乐由Eric Farndeller创作。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须注明对Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。